hallo hallo hallo btf was jetzt hallo Vodafone Vodafone Vodafone hallo also
battlefield ist nicht ausgelockt auf jeden fall geht wieder nice warum hast du den deaf
operator gesperrt hast du dich verklickt also was fragt denn hier fatal sag mal läuft das noch
oder oder ist das irgendwie broken dq also sag mal hab seit einer woche ein ganz komisches
problem mit meinem pc hatte 2 mal 8 gigabyte ddr 3 riegel ddr 3 dann ist der pc aber doch
schon ein bisschen älter seit letzter woche startet er nicht mehr mit beiden riegel aber
beide funktionieren habe jeden einzeln schon probiert ebenso wie alle slots hab aber hardware
technische bis auf ein paar hdd installiert kann es sein dass er nicht so viel power brauchen das
nicht naja festplatten verbrauchen hauptsächlich beim anlaufen viel strom also wenn die an das
anlaufen überleben also spätestens mit einem reset sollten ja nicht neu anlaufen das kann ich
remote schlecht diagnostizieren ich würde mal den ram test machen in so einem test oder sowas also
wenn die queue ist nicht gleich ob welche waffen sind meter weiß ich nicht welche waffen sind meter
m9 bei mir m9 und grad 30 was ist denn zu allgemein meter ak ak 24 glaube ich ak ist bei
bei sturm gewähren ziemlich meter zu deiner nachricht achso ja du kannst ein bild schicken
solang es nicht von rick ashley ist und mich rick rollen bild kannst du machen der out das
game train ist am start leute eins ab brauchst noch eins ab dann haben wir den den den scam dann
dann seid ihr in der abo falle wo kann ich das schicken ja sucht ihr irgendeine image hosting
seite aus jetzt bin ich in q 2 von 4 sogar schon der kuchen anders gore ist am start
dankeschön progas halb das ist jetzt ruckelt ist normal weil das game der meinung ist im
menü braucht man 100 prozent cpu last muss man 100 prozent cpu last erzeugen ne image hosting ich
kann nicht in discord hier reingucken gescheit also ich glaube aber nicht ich glaube auch nicht dass
es an der festplatte liegt 2 ja das spiel mag nicht dass wir join oder da werden auch leute
aus diesem spiel quitten es quitten ständig leute aus dem game raus wisst ihr was was wenn
die was wir jetzt mal machen in der zwischenzeit wir stellen mal unser super tolles profil ein
player card was kann man da so alles einstellen specialist images specialist also zeigt man ja
was ist das field of operation alles klar das problem jetzt mp9 also ein auto so ein auto
problem auch ich finde das lustig dass sie dann ein boot haben und es existiert in diesem spiel
da kein boot weiß auch nicht was man sich da so genau dabei überlegt hat smg brodachy kills
euer smg brodachy richtig brodachy badges mckay master kann man nicht noch mehr machen
machen wir so ok tags sie sind wett data meiner
ehrlich gesagt juckt mich das so überhaupt nicht
ground breaker so super so vielleicht geht es irgendwann auch los demnächst
bettel wie sieht es aus was der stand der runde
ich vermisse diese zeit wo man sich emblem selber gestalten konnte also ich vermisse
diese zeit auch und auch nicht weil erinnert sich einen black ops 1 90 prozent der player
cards bestanden aus dicks oder tippen foto ab google ok so gewonnen easy dann geht es
jetzt los klar also ergeblich bin ich noch in der queue aber sollte ja gleich funktionieren
so also was sieht man hier es ist auf jeden fall schon mal richtig
nice ist ekearec oder falls es ekearec sind keine ahnung auf jeden fall schon mal richtig
big brain zusammen mit zusammengeschraubt warum du so ultra viele strom strom fressen
des surfer hast oder ich weiß ich das von dir oder von wem ist das
es leht ich will nicht dass es leht das ist vermieter ja ich guck gleich ich guck gleich
weiter da hat sogar eine konsole gucken wir gleich ach manifest jetzt
manifest finde ich ist die beste map im spiel aber in rush leider schlecht gemacht ich glaube
manifest ist für alle anderen spielmodi mit das beste aber in rush ist es mit die schlechteste
ich weiß nicht was man sich dort mit den mit den platzierungen gedacht hat
oh was gehen mit dem kran hier oben ab was hat der kran für schmerzen
ja ich sag dir ich sag dir gleich was was da abgeht aber sowieso ich kann dir zwar sagen
was was ist so ungefähr aber mehr als sieht aus wie so was sieht aus wie storage sieht
aus wie netzwerksachen kann ich dir natürlich auf dem bild auch nicht sagen weil woher
soll ich wissen
oh oh depends man
ok das war nicht so gut das war ein low iq grappling hook wir müssen mal kurz warten
bis das zack zack ich muss kurz warten bis es reloaded hat jetzt
ok nice hier geht was ok das war pepega aimed was hatte mich gekillt m5 ah m5 enjoyer seh
schon ein richtiger m5 enjoyer muss auch mal sein
da kommt ein pence man
cap'n poggers ich hol dich yolo res oh nee
oh oh shit da ist ja ne panzer auf der straß
dafür mach ich ne krasse flank action aber nein ja manifestes pence champ
extreme nerd danke für den sub oh hier sehr guter spawn
exzellente exzellente exquisita spawn
oh oh ganz schlecht ganz schlecht
du kannst ja grad echt nichts machen der hat sich auch nicht selbst geheilt
aber wir haben es guck mal wir haben es gelegt legehänge ist die legehänge ist strong heute
steigt aus
ok vielleicht kriegen wir jetzt ein bisschen struktur rein
alles klar nice gg battlefield
what the hell ist das ist das ne hacker man fähigkeit oder oder war das geleckt
ist leute ist das ich bin verwirrt
ist das ne fähigkeit von dem specialist oder oder es ist lege gewesen
wenn sie fähigkeit von dem specialist ist würde ich auch ziemlich ziemlich ein pence
champ finden
leck warum nicht beides das ist ne gute frage warum nicht beides
ja der bruder bruder get wrecked
wenn wenn mechanics im game sind die nicht funktionieren dann triggert mich das immer
so ein bisschen bot fähigkeit weiß nicht das war glaube ich richtig
krasses gelege hätte die rechte ecke gucken sollen anscheinend
es einfach durchrennen aber ich dachte laut map der ist irgendwie da
ist auch immer besser als die esl matches von letztens
oh hier unten geht es ab wie nix abgekriegt nix abgekriegt
ich habe keine ahnung wo hier was abgeht
die die die die enjoyen das nicht so hier
sag mal können wir sterben blies
das spiel hat ja kein soundtrack deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mache einfach mal
thematisch passende musik an
ich finde das passt auch ziemlich gut dazu
oder was sagt ihr
es ist es ist auf jeden fall besser es ist auf jeden fall besser als der normale soundtrack
weil der normale soundtrack ist ja nicht vorhanden
game blies kann aber einer sterben
vielleicht kriege ich den rett hier oben ist viel am start ja
wir bräuchten irgendein mit amok jetzt auch hier oben geht es aber rund
hier oben geht es aber rund
oh was ist hier los ist das auto ich brauche muni ich brauche muni
übrigens habe ich schon mal gesagt dass ich die nachlade animation von der von der
lg 18 eigentlich ziemlich nice finde
ok achtung ein nicer rusher
also die spawns in wirklich komplette katastrophe hier in
der katastrophe
rauf aufs dach
oh ist er hinter mir
schon wieder leer
ich bin froh dass es kein radio gibt
wenn es ein radio geben würde dann müsste ich das radio muten weil mittlerweile tost
auf twitch ist
die mp ist nur auf range gut auf entfernung sagt es mal richtig
das hier ist die mitnehmen habe ich in der ak gesehen
das hier ist anscheinend so die krass so die mit die richtige meta waffe gerade
mit diesem attachment glaube ich auch probieren wir mal die meta waffe aus
ich meine ich bin ja froh ich bin ja froh dass es eine assault rifle gibt was man spielen
kann weil ansonsten
alles ein grund dass die alle ppega 29 gespielt haben
meine motion sensors mehr schmeißen
wo ist hier was ich sehe die gegner sterben und leute sterben neben mir aber
sehr gut hab wieder top funktioniert
ihr seht ihr wie die motion balls lagen
habt ihr es unten auf der map gesehen wie der motion ball einfach flupp flupp flupp
flupp
so als rush nur wieder mit der k30 rein viel besser
der könnt sich umdrehen und mich retten macht er nicht
jawoll kein respawn ist poggers
kein respawn timer ist der beste respawn timer
also wenn ich bin wenn es für mich für die gegner nicht
weggespray die guten
lege henne und heal
dankeschön game
da oben auf dem turm hat das einen single player
die haben 5 eingestellt und auf den single player verzichtet
um sich nur auf den multiplayer zu konzentrieren
und ich finde das sieht man auch
die musik ist perfekt finde ich passt richtig gut dazu
aber die haben wir gerade schon weggeklatscht
die skins sind nicht nur dämlich die sehen auch noch dämlich aus
also die fault dinger die gehen ja noch halbwegs
die fault dinger sehen halt dafür aus dass es richtig clone army ist
also in battle field 3 funktioniert deine maus nicht
warum das denn nicht
achja wir wollen uns ja das server build hier wieder weiter angucken
also was sehe ich denn hier sonst noch drauf
also ich sehe hier unten plate center sind das ernsthaft plate center
sieht ein bisschen aus wie plate center ich erkenne es nicht so wirklich
das ist von der von der größe her schlecht zu erkennen
es könnten auch festplatten einschübe sein aber
ich würde so spontan das hier oben sind festplatten einschübe
das hier sind auch festplatten einschübe die sind keine plate center
das sind festplatten einschübe das sieht man hier oben das metall dran
ist von der größe her nicht ganz klar
oder wobei das sind es doch plate center schwer zu erkennen
hpc 7.000 möglich ja
kann durchaus sein so das ist auf jeden fall storage
relativ viel frage ist halt nur ob große platten oder nicht
ich meine so ein storage kann durchaus auch wenig storage sein
der heutigen zeit ich hab ich hab festgestellt es wurden heute
30 terabyte platten vorgestellt eine konsole was mich ein bisschen stutzig
macht eine konsole mit windows das schon äußerst pains
champig ist ein patch panel noch ein patch panel
wer zu sagen das hier ist das dürfte irgendwie ein dsl modem sein
das hier in der mitte noch mal noch mal einen storage ist da oben
keine ahnung ja was der da typ mit dem keller macht
ist wirklich sehr fragwürdig keine ahnung ja es ist auf jeden fall nicht
nicht billig so viel so viel ist sicher
das ist eine ganz schlechte idee max
alter meine fresse battlefield movement please lass mich doch einfach mal da hochlaufen
wow fuck alter seht ihr wie viel dahinter mir ist
das sind 40 leute hinter mir ok es können nicht sein es können maximal
16 sein aber trotzdem
alter krass ist das pp geheim aller zeiten aber hat gereicht
jetzt gehen wir schon rein warum gehen wir rein weil es noch zwei
sekunden sind und jetzt gehts auf jawoll massive
ich kann nicht retzen
der waffensound ist tatsächlich in ordnung wobei man sagen muss für battlefield verhältnisse
finde ich ihn gar nicht mal
so gut also ihr seht auf range geht mit dem ding nicht so viel rein
ja komm on
ich wollte den den den container aufmachen und reingehen
das war doch range gerade da ging nicht so viel rein
und obwohl ich schon burst geschossen habe nice
schon planten am start
kann man sich eigentlich
hätte auch sein können
ja der kill danach schon
jawoll aufgeholt bunny bunny gehobt
hier überrennen die aber schon ganz schön oder
also balance ist wirklich was anderes
balance ist was anderes leute
und wir können doch nicht gehen wir können bei fünf bei so keine ahnung bei zehn sekunden
oder wann weiß ich jetzt
ich denke mal ich denke mal jetzt können wir gehen
habe ich glück jawoll es geht auf poggers
charlie mike
da ist ein dude dahinter und ohne sentry gun ist oder kommt ein gegner
ist wie weg oh oh sentry stellt
sentry stellt muss weg
von hinten
get fucked up in the ass over hier leute
sind die dauer
jetzt aber jetzt sind sie dauernd
ja ja ja ist gerade richtig anstrengend hier
ran hier ran hier leute
ran
so mal kurz kurz noch was reindrücken den booster impfung drinnen jetzt geht's los
ok ich war auf der falschen waffe
aber kann ja mal passieren die gegner haben ist ähnlich so wirklich viel resistance zu
spüren gerade
oh gott ist dieses spiel verpackt man
das spiel ist so verpackt
monach s
ich wurde ich habe gekrappelt und nach dem rest wurde ich beginnt das krabbel automatisch
aus dachau wieder schon ziemlich prognose oder schon schon ziemlich prognose
tot nach dem bus dann sus
war richtig sus
ich war schon längst um die eck
netcode 0 hd
also ist das halt mit kleinzeit hd detections muss auch so sein letztendlich
wie wir haben es nicht gekriegt
lul
guckt euch das mal an
hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
war das die bill gates booster
jawoll aus dach aus dach big brain dach
nein nein er stirbt gleich
oder
die sind alle unter ihm
ralphios
nein nein ralphios lass
nein ralphios ralphios please
ok ich gehe unten hin besser
ich sollte vielleicht lieber mal hier hinter so ein komisches
sorry weil die stellsten die stellsten ja hier rum
so motion motion balls
war nix wie weg
oh wie warum schießen die zurück
ich glaube jetzt erlauben die sich aber hier was
einfach zurückschießen
ich glaube
cake wait man
achtung achtung
huge
äh schlecht das war schlecht
weil von da hinten kommt was
ja ja ich weiß dass hinter mir einer ist
hinter mir ist noch mehr
ja ja ja ja ist ja gut
lass mich in ruhe
durchs fenster jawoll
boah hier drinnen ist ja die hölle los
äh
hier drinnen hier gehts ab
hier bräuchten wir jetzt irgendeinen panzer oder so
das wäre richtig nice
aber die machen das gut die gegner
muss man mal sagen endlich mal ihre leute die irgendwie so eine art taktik wenigstens
haben
so wenn ich glück habe kann ich da irgendwie reinsporn so
man kann ja auch die gegner die die die team jetzt nicht richtig selecten
weil ich das game denkt nope no pass hier drüber
lass mich spawnen spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn
nice
p h x
jetzt haben wirs
boah
alter warum kriegt man hier immer headshots
von was krieg ich bitteschön headshots ich spray einfach sinnlos auf die gegner drauf
kann doch keine headshots kriegen
aber wenn das game meint ich mein ich werd mich jetzt
ich werd mich natürlich nicht beschweren über headshots
von da hat er mich gehittet na gut
chat chain lore poc nice
ahja ja
chain lore ist am start dann kann er nix mehr schief gehen
whoop arrive leute whoop arrive
das emote haben wir dem chain lore zu verdanken
die weihnachts emote achja stimmt da war ja was
weihnachts emote da war ja was
wollt ihr weihnachts emote rein machen rein machen
übrigens hier probieren wir jetzt mal was es ist nicht auf dem dach a ist nicht auf
dem dach a ist in der mitte wir probieren mal oder fatal
ist schon am start ich wollte eigentlich versuchen ob man
herum flenken kann aufs dach und dann von oben reintroppen
aber ich glaube wir haben das schneller gelegt und gewonnen als ich irgendwie überhaupt
am objective bin
game game hallo
game
ah ok alles klar verstehe verstehe
manchmal klappt das
wir sprechen einfach lull das hat gehittet stolte stellt euch mal vor
easy win
the enemy is bugging out im wahrsten sinne des wortes
er möchte uns damit so was anderes sagen
überlegt euch mal wie schnell die runden starten könnten wieder
wenn wir uns diese cringe sprüche nicht jedes mal anhören müssten
dieses stage hat nie jemand getestet nö wahrscheinlich wie das meiste
ich habe ein equipment destroyed dass die meistens kills im squad hatte ist egal
hauptsache hauptsache ich habe ein equipment destroyed das ist mal richtig massive
da gibt es bestimmt bald demnächst eine badge für equipment destroyer
so was sehe ich denn hier sonst noch schönes drauf
also fox da habe ich keine ahnung was das ist
von der größe würde ich sagen fast ein lüfter oder so
hier unten das erkennt man zu schlecht erkennt man auch nicht
hier würde ich sagen tatsächlich auch irgendwelches netzwerk equipment oder so
aber jetzt mal ernsthaft das sind irgendwelche alten hp kisten dl 380
oder so was was macht dein nachbar damit im keller
oder dein mieter damit im keller das ist schon ein nichts zu unterschätzendes
equipment alles wahrscheinlich eher von ebay
und dementsprechend halt auch warm und energie fressend und laut
hat jemand eine ahnung was das hier in der mitte ist ist das ein fernseh
ist das ein fernseh ist das ein crt fernseh hier in der mitte oder was ist das
der macht web hosting ok web hosting im keller ist auch nicht
verkehrt leute wenn ihr zu einem ordentlichen
holster volt für eure für euer hosting ausrufezeichen hetzner im chat
20 euro startgut haben für alle eure hosting ansprüche und besser als das
das game wusste gerade nicht wo ich hin will
guck mal wir sind vor den defendern am mkong am mkong was ist denn das für ein
stumpfsinn game wer hat sich das wer hat sich das aus was hier los
nein in der s schicken er ist geschudet
wir haben a gelegt einfach schon nur wir waren wir waren vor den defendern da
das hat doch nie im leben jemand getestet oder wir haben wir haben die
erste base wir haben die erste base in luftgeschreckung in die luft
gesprengt bevor die defender überhaupt da waren
pepega testing sage ich mal dazu
das ist auch so ein teil der map hier den keiner warum warum existiert dieser
teil der map überhaupt
ergibt nicht wirklich sind hätte ja keine ahnung können dass sie dass es
geht näher hätte man vielleicht mal testen müssen aber ich glaube die haben
ihr spiel eh nicht gespielt ok wir gucken jetzt mal wie ich nein nein nein
ich renne jetzt einfach du triffst mich eh nicht soll du triffst mich nicht
pack nein
hier kommen welche motion sensors hin motion sensors
da unten ist er
easy das ist äußerst äußerst durchdacht gibt es im
Battlefield Revolution? Nö. Gibt es nicht.
Es kann eine Antenne einstürzen, das ist aber alles.
Monarch! Monarch S! Alter! Jetzt wurde aber zugesprägt. Die Maps sind einfach zu
big. Naja, in Rush geht es ja noch, aber ich gebe dir prinzipiell recht und die
Maps sind dann auch null für Rush ausgelegt.
Es gibt keine Revolution, wie man das aus Battlefield 4 kennt. Das einzige
Revolution Event ist das, was man im Trailer gesehen hat, wo die Seite vom
Schiff umfällt und dann gibt es noch halt diese Geschichte mit dem...
Okay, alles klar.
Da gibt es noch die Geschichte mit dem Mast auf dem Dach.
Aua! Die wollen es aber echt wissen hier. Ich verpiss mich mal kurz.
Fuck man! Aber jetzt gucken sie ja wirklich überall hin.
Das ganze Budget ging für den Tornado drauf, ja anscheinend. Der Tornado ist
auch eines der sinnlossten Features überhaupt. Benutzt jetzt nach dem, sag
man mal, nach dem anfänglichen Hype, benutzt irgendjemand diese Tornados
überhaupt, wenn sie kommen?
Also ich bin immer froh, wenn der Tornado nicht auf der Map spawnen, wo
ich hin möchte. Alter, wir haben hier eine ziemliche PP-Gap-Position.
Gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm! Bunny hop in die Deckung! Bunny hoppen in die
Deckung hat funktioniert. Jetzt geht's ran hier.
Gib ihm. Raus mit dem Crabling Hook und oben drauf.
Darf ich mal fragen von wo? Ach da, obvius, da hat, da, der, ah okay.
Das oben war ein Gegner? Wirklich? Ach das war ein Gegner! Ich dachte das ist ein
Teammate, null. Ja dann ist okay. Dann war, dann war es richtig, dann war es richtig
dumm. Ich dachte das ist, Moment, dann war der aber ganz schön langsam, oder?
Fuck! Wird der Roboterhund vom Tornado aufgesaugt? Weiß ich nicht.
Ich dachte das, ich hab den gesehen, ich dachte das wäre ein Teammate. Guck mal, da ist
übrigens Gehirntod. Gehirntod und Nutmage. Alles klar, wir haben, die Gegner, die Gegner wissen, wissen
was das ist. Okay, das wird wirklich gerade ziemlich, ziemlich knapp hier. Die pushen
doch jetzt auch gleich rum, die Jungs hier. So, erst mal kurz den Maul, sehr gut Max,
sehr gut. Pack, da komm ich nicht hin. Okay, oder auch nicht. Alter, Pepega Aim. Zu viel,
zu viel Hipspray, Mann. Zu viel Hipspray. Da wird man faul, ich sag euch, da wird, da
wird man faul und bewegt die Maus immer richtig. Alter, ist ja gut jetzt. Was die Umstände
bei DICE sollen echt nicht so geil sein, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich glaub die Kombination
aus DICE wissen nicht mal, wie man Battlefield macht plus EA macht Druck und nervt, da kommt
sowas raus. Oh, was ist das hier für ein Clusterfuck gerade? Da kommt was. What? Guter Play, das
hat er gut gemacht. Das hat er gut gemacht, das hat er taktisch geschickt gemacht, C4
um die Ecke und weg rennen. Das man muss das ja auch mal anerkennen können, wenn einer
was Gescheites macht. Die haben aber jetzt ziemlich, oh wir haben nur noch 6 Tickets,
wir verlieren. Leute, das ist die erste Runde, die wir losen. Was ist denn jetzt los? Losers,
Any Losers? Will ich verlieren? Gib ihm, gib ihm. Ahhhh. Erste Runde, die wir losen.
Erste Runde verloren. Wo blief? Ach, ihr hattet hier mal ein paar euch, Chet, der dort gearbeitet
hat, das ist interessant. Chet sagt, sie kennt einen DICE Entwickler. Ist das so wie früher,
wo man gesagt hat, mein Vater arbeitet bei Microsoft, du wirst gebannt oder kennst du
wirklich einen DICE Entwickler? Ja, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es nicht so
geil ist. Ich mein, wir haben uns ja letztens den, das mir gerade so eingefallen, wir haben
uns ja letztens mal ein paar Stellenbewertungen, also ein paar Arbeitsplatzbewertungen von DICE
angeguckt und die Leute haben ja auch geschrieben, sie verstehen nicht, wie man an den Wünschen,
also wie man so an den Wünschen der Spieler vorbei entwickeln konnte. Zehn Flagen in
einer Runde. Ja, wahrscheinlich random. Draus war schon ein gutes Quad und einen guten Heli-Flieger.
Ich glaube, wenn du einen guten Heli-Flieger hast, mit dem du mit kannst, das ist gar nicht
so unmöglich. Was macht euch der Captain Poggers, ist der wieder am Start? Poggers?
Ach guck mal da, das sparen wir jetzt rein. Übrigens, das ist der LLV, ich hätte das
nicht für Möglichkeiten, aber LLV ist schlecht gegen Infanterie, die haben in diesem Spiel
nichts getestet. Das Ding sollte eigentlich der Infanterie-Zerstörer sein. LLV, du alter
Zerstörer. Ist es aber nicht. Das Ding schießt zu langsam und macht zu wenig Splashdamage
und allgemein zu wenig Damage. Richtig hängen geblieben. Da geht einer auf B. Oh, oh, oh,
oh, über mir. Fuck, da hinten war er noch. Aber die Legehenne ist raus. Legehenne wurde
gemacht, Legehenne war erfolgreich. Mal gucken, ob die Legehenne durchgeht. Oh nee, ich glaube,
die diffusen. Nein, einfach diffuse. Oh, Jutsch. Oh, Combat, Combat, Combat. Der verreckt jetzt.
Oh, oh, oooh. Also, wir können noch eins, zwei für Squad gebrauchen, dass wir hier wieder
gut easy durchgehen. Guckt euch mal die Maps an. Es ist einfach offen. Einfach offen und
du musst jetzt da ranrennen. Oh jetzt hat das Bunnyhop nicht funktioniert. Jetzt muss
Irgendwie wieder mehr husten vielleicht klickt das auch mit anzahle das sind was ich erzähle wenn ich viel erzählen muss ich mehr husten oder
Wenn ich wenig erzählen keine ahnung
Ich sollte ein paar
Smokes mitnehmen
Verpiss dich ich baller einfach in deine richtung jetzt
Ja klar man
Omikron auf fack leute
morgen tot fack
Könnt schon das video hochladen
Youtuber stirbt bei live stream oder was auch immer
Was darf man als keine witzel drüber machen heutzutage weil doch man kann fast alles witzel machen
Guck mal der lhw macht keinen splash damage
Guck mal der lhw seht ihr wie der sackt, der sackt so hardcore der lhw man
Seht ihr das, seht ihr das
So schlecht man
Jetzt leckt er auch noch
Die musik passt ja ist wirklich so ein bisschen mario kart style
Ok tschüss und tschüss
Mal gucken ob wir wieder den nice move hier hinbekommen
Ja hat wieder funktioniert
Ich habe gedacht ich spreche aus der hüfte das war eine dumme idee ich hätte die iron sights gehen sollen
Ich dachte komm du machst einfach links rechts strafe und baller wild in die richtung
Das war nicht so schlau
Ein richtiger pepega move
Ein richtiger pepega move was ist da oben los
Okay jetzt aber
Leute wir haben schon gelegt, Leute wir haben schon die lege hände gemacht bevor ich überhaupt fertig bin
Das war ein hit
X daubt
Daubt, aber ganz große daubt das
Das war ein hit
Also ein könnten wir als zwei als zwei könnten wir für es konnt noch gebraun, weiß ob der captain po bleach noch mal kommt
Ja rühren und beten
Achtung wo ane ist ein schild im welch
Durfte nicht einsteigen war weil warum weil
Aber wir haben sie
Guck mal die jenkler haben das eigentlich ganz gut gemacht
Die haben uns auch die haben uns auch wirklich ganz gut im zaum gehalten aber das hat das game hat sich gedacht nope
Style down
Es ist übrigens extrem irritierend das tote gegner noch sprechen und man denkt dort ist was
Die haben übrigens auch nicht gefixt dass man gegner neber sich hört die 50 kilometer weg sind
auch so ein ding
Wenn er jetzt hat keiner getestet jetzt jetzt wird spannend wie
Achtung
Oh
Back
Liegt an der siedels soundkarte nein das legt da well viel problem hast du mehr oder weniger überall
Ach mensch jetzt leute seid man nicht so oft zack
Lk 0 sagt da das game heute deinstalliert kann ich verstehen
Also wenn ich nicht ab und zu mal hier noch ein streem
Streben würde und das mit mit euch zusammen halbwegs spaß machen würde würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr spielen ich habe das nur
Noch installiert wegen wegen stream sor
Ohne ist weil wir das hier macht mir tatsächlich echt spaß mit den leuten dabei jetzt
Jetzt geht wieder nix aber ich glaube der kriegt mich glaube der kann mich retten um die ecke
So ein paar motion sensors rüber kloppen
Bin mir nicht sicher wo hier was ist gerade noch mal noch mehr mauschen jetzt rüber rüber hier
Aus irgendwelchen pointen ist da oben was achtung mensch game come on
Es hätte so gut funktionieren können
Hat es aber nicht wir haben noch mal eine chance leute noch mal eine chance
Ach man das game fackt mich teilweise richtig ab
Man kann sich auch nicht mehr auf auf geländer stellen das funktioniert nicht so immer wenn du auf den geländer gehen willst springt da rüber
Rittenfriede für den zapp
Sagt
ist abel anzeige ist raus
Der typisch liegt bestimmt immer noch da ich spreide jetzt einfach dass er sich nicht traut
Okay die gegner das wird jetzt richtig zum es zum esl match hier
Lull wie so nicht das hast du dir so gedacht alda na
Das hast du dir so gedacht ich warte mal dass die beim dass er bei mir spawnen kann
Ah
Was hältst du von coding bootcamps?
Kommt drauf an!
Was das für ein thema ist und ob das mit oder ohne bezahlung ist oder oder oder je
nachdem also von der firma nicht von der firma irgendwas freiwilliges irgendwas hackerstellts
mäßiges oder alter ich habe 50 gegner um mich drum herum obwohl hier eigentlich gar
nichts ist weiß gar nicht wo der ist
der typ ist immer noch da oben ich fasse es nicht alter
ok wir müssen auf jeden fall noch motion sensor darüber klatschen jetzt dass wir was
sehen da oben ist ja die familien ist ja weihnachtsfeier da ist ja wirklich weihnachtsfeier drauf
einmal probiert ich habe noch ich habe übrigens noch nie erlebt dass es in stocken gerät
an dieser base das ist das ist mir neu ich glaube fast rush ist ziemlich defender heavy
wenn man einmal in stocken kommt jetzt einen sagen die leute ja klar max das ist rush aber
das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig so sein weiß gar nicht wo ich hin soll wir sind zu wenige
wisst ihr was wir gehen jetzt hierüber
nein ich weiß nicht was ich tue
sieht so aus als wüsste ich was ich tue
weiß nicht was ich tue steigt mal lieber ab jungs
monka stier
da hinter mir steht er monka stier aber vielleicht sind wir jetzt ein bisschen rangekommen
nein verloren so wir brauchen noch zwei teammates leute es geht nicht dass wir runden verlieren
zweite runde in folge verloren
das ist ausgeschlossen das ist only wind stream
der guckt schon so richtig pains champ
hast du schon mal drüber nach einer handschauderung zu spielen habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt
ich weiß was das ist dass das die das ist das crytek wie nennt man diese genre keine
ahnung
right jetzt ist ja kein battle royale es ist crytek
wie nennt man das genre von von handschauderung
kannst du mal zeigen wie das geht mit aufsätze level mit bots
ja das würde ich eigentlich zeigen bevor ich oft gehe weil sonst müssen die leute im
squad hier warten
oh nee our class battle kann ich mal kurz zeigen wie man aufsätze
leveled
auf our class habe ich eh keinen bock
würde sagen dauert 10 minuten oder so 10 10 minuten 10 15
also als nächster gehen wir die map auslassen ok also dann zeige ich euch das jetzt mal
schnell
wie man aufsätze leveled
also
zack
also ihr geht all out warfare
nein
achso ich bin nicht der party leader deswegen ich muss die party leaven
leave party
so ihr geht auf all out warfare
change game mode solo dann sagt ihr hier change settings mit f warum auch immer
und ihr müsst kaleidoskop auswählen und start
wichtig ist ihr müsst attacker sein aber ich glaube es gibt nur attacker wenn ihr solo
spielt
so und dann müsst ihr die erste base schnell clear
und dann aufs hochhaus und auf dem hochhaus gibt es den level bug glitch
wie auch immer man das nennen mag
ich euch
stellt die bots auf noob bots ist es egal ob ihr noob bots oder gute bots killt
überhaupt kein unterschied
zählt
übrigens ihr müsst auch wenn ihr solo spielt 5 stunden warten bis das game startet
warum weiß ich nicht müssen wir dice fragen
der grinst auch schon so
truckel übrigens bei mir auch das nicht nur bei euch im streben
so da müsst ihr hin guck hier oben hier auf dieses auf dieses haus müsst ihr klein
also erst mal erste und zweite base clear
erste zweite base clear
was gegen bots relativ einfach ist
und dann da oben da oben drauf hier oben ist so ein lüftungsschacht
da müsst ihr hin
eigentlich euch klein
ich weiß auch nicht ob es da nicht vielleicht bessere varianten gibt
im direkten panzer
panzer noobs
muss erst mal intro angucken
muss man die runde gewinnt für xp nein
es geht ja nicht um xp es geht ja um attachments freischalten
ich will nicht ich ach so shotgun level ja das können wir dann gleich machen
also ihr müsst jetzt erst mal also unser ziel ist glaube ich c1
wir müssen jetzt a2 a1 schnell machen dann b1 b gibt es nur ein objective wenn ich das
richtig im kopf habe
und ja dann ja ja bots lasst mich in ruhe
easy as fuck
so wir müssen jetzt erst mal die bots clear die hier rumstehen
ne das stirbt nicht
meine team mates sind richtig richtig richtig porgas
ok wenn wir glück haben kommen wir da jetzt schon ran und legen
ach das ist ja break through das ist ja gar kein rush
was erzähle ich denn hier legen man richtig hängen geblieben
so also a1 cap schon
drei stunden später
habt ihr gestern eine runde trat ja ich auch
ich habe fast die komplette fast die komplette k30 dort gelewelt
also einnehmen drei stunden später ist es dann irgendwann
eingenommen
dann geht es rüber zu a2 dann b2 und dann oben aufs haus
da kommt noch was ok wir haben es jetzt rüber
das müsst ihr auch nur einmal machen das könnt ihr euch auch ein bisschen zeit lassen
und die waffe leveln oder so das ist das ist easy
oh nein die bots sind gar nicht so dumm
das war jetzt schlechtes beispiel hier waren die bots jetzt wirklich dumm
aber an sich sind die bots gar nicht gar nicht so dumm
ja der bot killt mich gleich team komm on please
ok da konnte ich jetzt gar wirklich nix machen
es ist wirklich wenn du akkus ziehst von den bots
achja übrigens meine teammates sind so schlau die wiederbeleben nicht
die haben da schon mal gar kein bock drauf
richtiges bot team ja korrekt
aber das machen wir jetzt schnell das zeige ich ihr könnt auch wunderbar die waffe leveln
guck mal also easier kriegt ihr keine 20 kills
so team please kommt mal rein
kommt mal rein team auf gib ihm wir gehen jetzt einfach hier oben
drauf das kann euch das kann euch bei bot battles
manchmal passieren dass euer team wirklich nicht nicht nachrückt
und das ist dann natürlich pains champ er so nehmt ne muni kiste mit leute
das ist das allerwichtigste ihr müsst ne muni kiste mitnehmen
muni kiste mitnehmen unglaublich wichtig ihr braucht ne muni kiste
ohne muni kiste könnt ihr das nämlich gleich auf dem dach nicht machen
ok ich glaub wir haben es steht hier einer in der eck
so das jetzt ne ihr braucht ne muni kiste weil ihr auf dem dach später keine möglichkeit
habt euch zu refreshen
ihr müsst muni kiste und mckay ist auch ein dummer specialist
ihr müsst maria falck mitnehmen maria falck für sehr viel und ammo kiste
das ist das ist eigentlich das eigentliche meta für waffen unlocks
das heißt ich werd mich nochmal killen lassen wenn wir das hier eingenommen haben
und so jetzt brauchen wir noch eine eine genau das hier brauchen wir jetzt noch b1
und dann gehts hoch aufs hochhaus und dann ist unlock waffen unlock farmen
angesagt true luvie genau
komm mal macht das eigentlich damage macht das hier damage
lass mich mal kurz so durchrushen b1
der grappling hook hat auch 50 prozent damage gemacht noch vorm patch
weiß nicht warum es das jetzt nicht mehr macht
hier ist das problem die bots sind zu dumm
die bots sind zu dumm hier durchzukommen das heißt ihr müsst auf jeden fall das
clearen sonst wird das nix und nachdem ihr euch heilen müsst
wie gesagt maria falck ammo pack midi midi midi stels
die sind alle hier unten die bots guckt
irgendwas hinter mir stellts da jetzt rum so mein team ist halt so richtig
richtig schnell
okay jetzt switchen wir mal auf die eigentlich sinnvolle klasse dafür
komm mal schon schon 42 kills für fast nix ihr braucht 300 kills ihr braucht 300 kills
für für alles
okay also jetzt switchen wir mal auf die sinnvolle klasse dafür
also maria falck midi pack
schiebt da rein mit dem g baited beste musik dafür
so da unten ist wieder alles voll
ich hab da so viel gekillt die müssten es eigentlich ohne probleme hinbekommen aber
ich meine das sind bots darf man nicht vergessen
mein teammates können sich reviven ich probiere das mal ob die ob die reviven ob die so schlau
sind und reviven können aber das geht glaube ich nicht
auto ja die lasern dich teilweise
huge car steuerung monka monka steer das war keine so gute idee
okay jetzt aber hier
sag mal ich muss bots bashen alter ich will euch einfach nur zeigen wo man waffen levelt
aber gerade wollen die bots nicht
aber noch irgendwas spannendes
es gibt übrigens auch keine squats in diesem modus
die ai geht manchmal richtig ab
das ziel ist ja waffenleveln deswegen finde ich mit autos gar nicht mal so sinnvoll
die bots können mehr
nee ich hab das gestern auch gemacht das ist easy as fuck
ich hab ich hab da zehn minuten für gebraucht
alter okay jetzt aber
du musst dich richtig anstrengen man gegen die bots
sollen es so
jetzt haben wir es aber
ich glaube jetzt haben wir es meine güte das war ja schwere geburt
das war eine schwere geburt so wenn wir das haben es gibt nur b1 was anderes gibt es
nicht
dann kommt die geschichte mit dem haus auf die kommt es an
deswegen braucht ihr auch die muni kiste sonst wird das ganze nicht
ich meine guck mal ich hab schon 58 kills
kann man easy kills machen zwischendurch
so wir haben es und jetzt geht das andere auf
und jetzt und jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt wird es
muss man nicht angel nehmen nur ich hab das auch ohne angel gestern gemacht
es gibt es gibt bestimmt zig taktiken für ich hab es gestern so gemacht
ich hab es gestern so gemacht ich bleib mal hier bevor es die bots noch verlieren
also ich ich hab es gestern so gemacht weil du hast ammo box und du kannst dich selbst
verteilen
ist wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich geschmackssache
so jetzt müssen wir hier oben hin
da da hoch c1
c1 hinter und da müssen wir möglichst schnell hoch bevor die 30 milliarden bots da sind
ich bin jetzt mit dem heli hochgeflogen das hat gut funktioniert
als als passagier wir gucken ob wir es mit dem fahrstuhl auch schaffen
aber wahrscheinlich wirst du komplett weggespreit im fahrstuhl schon
da da müssen wir hin da ist so eine luftschacht und da muss man hin
ohne heli wirst du es gelasert mal gucken ich hab es noch nicht probiert mit dem fahrstuhl
wo sind die fahrstühle noch mal hier
wo sind die fahrstühle
hier rechts
da hier
pass auf ich werde jetzt weggelasert von den bots
also da dahin nicht der ach der ah ja falsche seite
so so müsste ich einmal durch das einmal durch das dach das wird nichts also wir müssen
hier raus und an die recht rechts runter was wahrscheinlich nichts wird
probieren wir mal ansonsten ansonsten mit dem heli ansonsten mit dem heli rauf
und es kann ja auch ein bisschen dauern
so hier hin müsst ihr leute hier hin und jetzt einfach nur ihr legt hier hinten das
ding hin und jetzt
jetzt fahrt ihr eure 300 kills
die bots können euch nicht hitten
du kannst auch hier man kann auch hier drüber gucken das geht auch
aber ich habe es gestern so gemacht hin hingelegt ich habe es im prinzip so gemacht
ich habe mich in mein ammo pack gelegt ammo pack hier hin
ich habe mich in mein ammo pack gelegt und ungefähr
ungefähr zehn minuten hier gelegen ach so ihr dürft nicht so viele bots killen sonst
passiert das
eure ai gewinnt und das ist schlecht ihr wollt nicht dass eure ai gewinnt
eure ai soll verrecken das war jetzt dumm ich habe zu viele bots gekillt
also ich warte jetzt mal bis meine ai hoffentlich stirbt
hoffentlich hoffentlich stirbt meine ai leute kratzt mal ab
aber ihr habt es gesehen das ist im prinzip das ist im prinzip der trick
ok meine ai ist tot sehr gut das ist der trick
ja
nein ich würde auf gar keinen fall belphi kaufen gerade
so und da macht ihr jetzt einfach eure 300 kills
bleibt hier in diesem ammo pack liegen und und seit ironside enjoyer
fertig und legt euch irgendwie so hin dass es nicht rumklitscht
so funktioniert das die bots können euch nicht hin
die einzige sache wo euch die bots manchmal hitten könnten ist von hier
und deswegen lege ich mich da unten hin ja du kannst nur aufsätze leveln
ich lege mich so hin weil das checken die bots nicht
so was wollte ich leveln auto shotgun
waren wir jetzt aber nicht im stream so also ihr habt es gesehen easy
so funktioniert das und da habt ihr in einer viertelstunde die
waffe frei auf gehts
ihr da ist hast diesen trick ja wahrscheinlich weil jetzt können die
leute easy alles anlocken aber ganz ehrlich ich finde das ist auch
notwendig das ist ich ganz ehrlich ich finde das anlocken in dem game ist so
eines der unenjoyigsten sachen aller zeiten toller satz also es macht überhaupt
kein bock sachen hier frei zu spielen weil es gibt alles doppelt und dreifach
und eigentlich gibt es ja auch nur sagen wir mal 2 1 2 kombinationen die du
haben willst du willst bei den smgs willst du das 40 und 50 40 und 50 ja
merkt haben fertig in einem spiel kann konquest nur im moment
also den sinn verstehe ich nicht so genau warum in portal xp aus ist und
solche dinger im single player halt easy möglich sind gegen portal spielst du
immer noch gegen echte leute
gut ich meine natürlich ist xp und das nicht genau das gleiche aber trotzdem
normalerweise sollte ja auch das anlocken mit zum game gehören aber ich
finde es macht überhaupt keinen spaß und so kann man wie gesagt ihr habt
gesehen viertelstunde und ihr habt alles anlockt
oh wir sind die fände haben wir uns die fände geben was meinst du ich spiele
wir spielen mal ein zwei runden die fände dass wir war auch aus die fände
auch nicht bin fack ich bin falscher specialist leute ich habe falsche setup
es muss ein medik oma spielen medik oma ohne mobility ist in rastum
ich bin ironside enjoyer oder fack moment mal ich will mich heilen
shit hätte drei tricken müssen jetzt du fragst dich warum es überhaupt einen
modus gibt ich denke mal das ist dass man das spiel üben kann weil die davon
ausgehen dass die leute so schlecht sind dass die auch mal entspannt gegen bot
spielen müssen wenn es wenn es ist das leider
da komme ich nicht rein all da hier ist ja alles voll
fack zu früh ausgemacht
shit es hätte klappen können es hätte klappen können ich hätte es vielleicht
eher von der sauer nice danke die gehen jetzt für den retz da oben da kann ich
auch schnell hoch aber von der seite game please das wollte ich doch gar nicht
was was genau hat mich gerade gekillt hat es jemand mitbekommen was was was
was genau hat mich gekillt
spielt eigentlich ein menschen herz hat so und wahrscheinlich nicht
wüsste auch nicht warum man herz hat so und spielen sollte es hat so nicht so ein
modus der macht für zweier übrigens wisst ihr was mit meinem da ist feedback
passiert ich habe es euch doch letztens vorgelesen die haben ja wirklich die
nerven noch nach feedback zu fragen er meinte er hat das noch mal
gefiltert und manche punkte aufgenommen also es war wahrscheinlich nicht nett
genug was ich geschrieben habe um das an die verantwortlichen badeis weiter zu
leiten
ja verstehen mein wo kämen wir dahin wenn die auch damit konfrontiert werden
würden dass ihr spiel sagt das geht ja nett also das sind wir uns ja einig
irgendwie die realität ist ja aktuell 2021 allgemein nicht mehr hoch im kurs
youtube deaktiviert ja auch dislikes nicht ohne grund wir machen jetzt big
brainmove leute big brainmove next level shit oh oh oh sehr viel nice lass
mich weg und tschüss und tschüss nice grappling hook grappling hook enjoyer
ok pass mal auf pass mal auf alles klar kritik fähigkeiten so das war doch mal
nice play oder easy hat er mich getbackt oder hat es nur so ausgesehen hat er
mir wirklich getbackt glaube ich wissen gar nicht was das ist
oh nice nice
bin mir nicht ganz sicher wo die wo die gegner gerade enjoyen
da enjoyen die gegner aber richtig richtig richtige flanke enjoyer sind das
hier kommen wir das auch kann
push mich push mich push mich gachi bass was zum was zu
der war doch überm schild warum er warum ging da eben gar nichts rein
habt ihr das gesehen
verstehe nicht im ortel ja oder war das wieder leck die getter sind ja stimmt
die getter da kann man also richtig durch schießen ist mir auch schon
aufgefallen
komisch richtiger richtiger dass ich nicht treff enjoyer no no hit rack
enjoyer manchmal geht's manchmal nicht das ist über range so gut oh get fucked
up in the ass over hier mein es v m l l r
generell ist viel spiel ist rad viel einiges random nicht nur nicht nur die
getter ob es immerhin hier big plane pass big
plane posi
oh nee hier ist aus hier sauer auf map schitt nicht so gut
fuck gut es wusste jetzt nicht von wo der kommt ist das spiel eigentlich sehr
enttäuscht oder spiel sehr enttäuschend ich bin mega enttäuscht über das
spiel ist no cuppa wirklich ihr habt wenn man video gesehen hat weiß das
wahrscheinlich ich bin ultra enttäuscht über das game
lull pepega emt habt ihr das gesehen
denn auch hier ne oder ist das nicht mehr da
ja wo gehen wir jetzt hin mal zur a würde ich sagen die pusht eigentlich in
der regel immer auf art zuerst map mal kurz map check nicht noch check map
check alles klar da sind sie slidermann ok auto da war wir nicht hin
angel did it again hinter mir hinter mir mensch
in der ask schuldet wieder hallo die checkens die checkens auch nicht
pepega pepega scheibenwischer pepega scheibenwischer richtig aber hat
funktioniert alter 20 jetzt geht aber ab mit dem wichtigen supply trop ja das
supply tropf ist so was von wichtig wichtigstes gadget wichtigste
fähigkeit überhaupt man merkt an dem supply tropf ja überhaupt nicht dass es
mal ein battle royale oder sowas in der richtung werden sollte ja ich weiß jetzt
kommen wieder die super krassen historiker die sagen max es gab noch
auch schon im battlefield 2 einen supply tropf oder irgendwie sowas in der
richtung meine wirklich die haben das eingebaut weil es es schon im
battlefield 2 gab ich meine es gab in battlefield 2 viele coole sachen diese
nicht eingebaut haben manche der supply tropf ist drinne weil das
battlefield 2 auch drinne ist oder weil das gut wäre für den battle royale oder
für hesser zonen muss battlefield 2 sein muss battlefield 2 dann es lag
bestimmt daran dass es den supply tropf auch schon in battlefield 2 gegeben hat
also manchmal frage ich mich echt ob so die so die kommentiere auf youtube und
reddit und so ob die wirklich jegliche gehind zellen verloren haben wenn so
was geschrieben wird ok mal gucken ob man da oben drauf kann
oh nice da kann man oben drauf nice oh was ist das für komische lag man
richtiger pains pains chamble aber wir haben gleich gewonnen das
schneiber man schneiber man erstmal sprengen in die ecke rein das kann ich
nicht kontest mit meiner smg über die range also man hat man hat schon mal
gewonnen wenn die gegner kämpen als attacker in ihrem spawn das was das
kann zwei zwei möglichkeiten haben wenn die attacker im spawn kämpen man ist
entweder so krass überlegen oder die spawn sind blöd
ich tippe gerade mal auf beides wir sind wir sind besser als die gegner
und die spawn sind dumm das kommt beides
wer warum soll ich warum ein zeit wer braucht ein zeit leute wer braucht ein
zeit wenn er einfach aus der hüfte spray sollen kann
was auch immer ach ich falle auf das schild alter lull
ok wir haben gewonnen es gibt bloß noch drei gegner
richtig gesprüht und gebetet mal gucken was ich angeblich wichtiges gemacht habe
also 30 kills waren ja nicht wichtig mal gucken was ich wichtiges gemacht habe
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich hipfire kills oder sowas was habe ich wichtiges
gemacht hipfire kills endlich gut zu wissen
also das game denkt wirklich hipfire kills ist ganz wichtig
kann ich jetzt das kann ich immer im battle battle log profil schreiben 13
rekord 13 hipfire kills die musik passt richtig gut dazu finde ich die musik ist
richtig richtig richtig kogas
renewal
es gibt noch bettel oder leider hat man sich dafür entschieden
kein bettel log zu machen leute ich wusste heute ein bisschen muss mich
manchmal räuschen wegen trockenem hals aber es ist besser als gestern oder mal
so an die frage oder vorgestern war der letzte stream war also ich heute ich
wusste heute schon weniger und man so weniger hals probleme als im stream
vorher oder finde ich auch
ist schon besser geworden also anscheinend bringt eukalyptus dampfbart
und salbei t was
omikron der schweiß jet alles klar
aber eigentlich hoch wäre auch zu zu kogas pogas gewesen wenn man hier hoch
kann was denn da hinten
als jetzt schreckt der lv sagt vor dem lv muss man keine angst haben
was mit dir los stelz nicht der stelzer der oberstelzer
wo ist denn hier was die gegner kommen wieder gar nicht aus dem spawn raus
wated er dacht aber
Oh fuck, jetzt hab ich mich verschluckt. Ich wurde Hacker-Man.
In den Kopf. Ich mag McCree. Leute, im Kern, ich sag's euch, im Kern, das Spiel hat schon
manche Sachen, die cool sind. Also ich mag das Movement hier auch mit dem Köppling und
so was. Man kann sich jetzt streiten, ob's Battlefield ist, aber es ist halt einfach
so unten nicht zu Ende gedacht. Au. Und die kriegen grad richtig, richtig reingefahren.
Richtig reingefahren kriegen sie. Ja, schlau Max, sehr schlau, schlau, schlau von dir gewesen,
in das brennende Ding rein zu rennen. Sehr schlau, richtig, richtig Big Brain Poggers.
Was, da war noch einer, den hab ich nicht gesehen. Habt ihr den gesehen? Der ist bestimmt da
gespawnt. Chat sagt, Battlelog war für die damalige Zeit echt top, hat sich sehr gut
mit den Platoons ergänzt. Battlelog find ich heut immer noch top. Könnt ihr euch vielleicht
noch dran erinnern, so wie ich bin. Ich hab am Anfang gegen Battlelog geflamed, weil
ich gesagt hab, oh ist das dumm, dass man da aus dem Game muss, aber ich bin relativ
schnell auf den Richter gekommen. Ich mein, ich hab am Anfang auf der Xbox gespielt,
ja kein Wunder. Ich bin relativ schnell auf den Richter gekommen, dass Battlelog eigentlich
ziemlich Poggers ist. Generell muss man echt mal sagen, mit Battlefield 3, die waren ihrer
Zeit voraus, insofern, die waren halt richtig innovativ und haben was richtig Gutes, Zusammenhängendes
gebaut. Was sie danach meiner Meinung nach in der Form nie wieder hinbekommen haben,
Battlefield 4 ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht schlecht und auch mittlerweile richtig gut
gepatcht, aber nicht zu vergleichen zum Release in Battlefield 3. Die kriegen gerade richtig
reingefahren die Gegner. Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass ich Battlefield 3 nicht so gut finde,
es ging zum Release, in welchem Zustand die Games war und Battlelog wurde mit Battlefield
3 erfunden. Da kannst du sagen, was du willst, die waren ihrer Zeit innovativ, also die waren
einfach richtig innovativ damals. Die Gegner sehen keine Sonne gerade, oder? Die Gegner
campen schon wieder nicht mehr, mein Spring ist kaputt, mein Springbutton funktioniert
mal wieder nicht. Manchmal funktioniert auch der Nahkampfbutton nicht, das ist immer gut,
wenn man das Tasten einfach mal spontan anbindet. Wackfreies Spiel. Jaja, der LVsack, der kann
nicht springen, ich würde gerne springen, aber ich kann nicht springen, weil meine Springtaste
anbindet wurde. Seht ihr, wie schlecht der LV ist? Ich kann nicht springen. So pains
Champ, so dumm. Ok, nice. Ja, also was war Battlelog? Ich zeige euch, was Battlelog war,
während ihr die nächste Runde sucht. Für alle, die sich kennen, Battlelog war ein Browser,
also ein Webservice und Browser Addon in einem, wo du quasi Serverbrowser und Profilverwaltung
und Progress Tracking, hoops, ich wollte nicht auf Battlefield 1 gehen, ich wollte auf Battlefield
3 gehen, im Browser hattest. Und sowas ist einfach im Browser tausendmal besser als in
Game, weil Webbrowser und HTML, CSS, JavaScript Sachen ist für sowas einfach richtig prädestiniert.
Und du hattest einen Serverbrowser, du konntest aussuchen, was du spielen willst, konntest
danach suchen und hast dann gesagt, ok, ich will jetzt Operation Metro spielen, groß,
sehr schön, vielen, sehr schön, bam, join. Dann hat dein Game gestartet und ist direkt
draufgegangen. Du hast auch gesehen, was das, du konntest dir auch die Server-Settings angucken,
konntest du sagen, aha, Server Rotation, Terran, Highway, Sand Crossing, Metro, Firestorm mag
ich nicht so, Damavant Peak, Hark Island, ok, die haben coole Maps. Du konntest dir sogar
Ränge anzeigen lassen, der Spieler, mit dem du gespielt hattest. Du hattest eine History,
was deine letzten Matches waren, du konntest Leute adden, du konntest dementsprechend auch
bestimmen, was du spielen magst und was nicht. Falls du keinen Bock hast auf Hourglass, hättest
einfach Hourglass nicht ausgewählt oder einen Server rausgesucht ohne Hourglass Rotation,
Battlelog war richtig nice. Warum die das abgeschafft haben, weil ich glaube, dass Battlelog
ziemlich schlampig implementiert war und die einfach zu blöd war und es ihnen zu viel
Wartungsaufwand letztendlich war, weil die mussten ja trotzdem ein Ingame-Menü für
Konsole machen. Konsole hat ja, konnte man eigentlich, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, Chet,
konnte man mit der Xbox über Battlelog, weil man einen PC hatte, mit den Servern joinen?
Ging das? Also man konnte sein Profil tracken und sowas im Battlelog, das wusste ich, aber
konnte man Server joinen und Server suchen für Xbox? Ja? Ne, das ging nicht, oder? Ich
spreche übrigens da einfach mal sinnlos rein, ich denke, dass ich was kill. Ne, ging nicht,
ne? Max hört sich mit dem Mic an, wieso, stimmt was mit meinem Mikrofon nicht? Ich
glaube, ich bin ein bisschen heißer oder so. Auto-tune. Oh shit, ich wollte da hoch. Ja,
es haben damals viele geheult bei Battlelog, das stimmt, weil das was Neues war und wie
das so ist, bei neuen Sachen wird oftmals erstmal rumgeheult, aber es hat sich dann
relativ schnell, also eigentlich so nach dem ersten Monat oder so gelegt und die Leute
haben Battlelog gefeiert, ich auch. Ich auch. Ich habe am Anfang auch gesagt, ich finde
Battlelog doof, dass du nicht mehr im Game den Browser hast und sowas, aber ich bin
dann relativ schnell auf den Dichter gekommen, dass Battlelog schon ziemlich nice ist. Die
hätten eigentlich richtig gut das ganze ausbauen können. Stellt euch mal vor, die hätten
eine API und eine Pluginschnittstelle für Battlelog gemacht. Wisst ihr, wie geil das
hätte werden können, wenn du quasi Custom Plugins für deinen Server oder deinen Squad
oder so erstellen könntest, wie auch immer, was man da mit machen könnte. Das wäre richtig
POG gewesen. Alter, wer hat dieses Innending hier designed? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es
runtergeht. Ah, hier. Ich bin gerade 30 FPS-Enjoyer, weil es laggt. Warum ruckelt das so im Hintergrund?
Warte mal, ich muss es hier mal zumachen. Runtermachen, Browser ausmachen. Warum ruckelt
das gerade so? Könnte Explosive gar nichts geplantet haben. Oh. 7 TV, 7 TV habe ich
nicht aktiviert. Max, willst du mitspielen? Oh ja. Bam, wo ist er? Nicht on. Also so 3-4
Runden machen wir noch, weil dann ist 22 Uhr und ihr wisst, was 22 Uhr ist. 22 Uhr ist
schon spät. Schon spät. Boomer schlafen, schon spät. Wo ist die Treppe? Oh shit. Oh,
oh. Oh, oh. Alter, das laggt ja mal so krass gerade. Nein, ich will, ich will ihn nicht
retten, ich will diffusen, man. Das Spiel, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Du diffusst
jetzt nicht, du rettest jetzt erst mal. Oh, da unten geht gut was ab. Oh, da ist. Fuck.
Alter, hier geht was, hier geht, hier geht gut was ab. Ich brauche meinen Motionball.
Was ein bescheuerter Soundeffekt. Ball, nein, nein, nein, lass mich nur. Alter, es ruckelt
hier. Leute, falls es bei euch ruckelt, es ist nicht nur bei euch so, es ruckelt hier.
Was ist das denn? Warum ruckelt denn das so? Ich glaube, das ist die Map. Ich habe gerade
gefühlt 30 FPS. Ich glaube, das ist Memory Leak. Man muss das Spiel ja öfters mal neu
starten, weil es Memory Leaks hat. Nein, da wollte ich nicht hin. Oh, oh, ich glaube,
jetzt wird geplantet. Also, Max, keine Ahnung, ob du mitspielen willst. Ich weiß, ich habe
es gerade nicht gelesen, aber wenn du mitspielen willst, kann ich dich nach der Runde entweiten.
Nee, nee, an den offenen Chrome Tabs liegt das nicht. Jetzt hat er die Runden vorher
auch nicht geruckelt. Ich glaube, das ist einfach huge. Ein nice Memory Leak. Gut, so
nice ist das nicht, aber es ruckelt. Obwohl ich angeblich 90 FPS habe, das fühlt sich
überhaupt nicht an wie 90 FPS. Was ist denn jetzt los? Warum ist die Map auf einmal kleiner
geworden? Ah, weil die es gesprengt haben. Ja, das war vorher auch nicht so. Das ist
auch eine dumme Implementierung. Ich kann kaum noch um die Ecke laufen, so sehr ruckelts.
Nee, das ist ja mal ganz pains jambig. Der Battlelog Bitcoin Miner. Ja, ich habe ja sogar
schon das Battlelog wieder zugemacht im Hintergrund. Ihr habt es nicht gesehen. Also, ich starte
nach der Runde neu das Game. Ich hoffe, ich bin so schnell, dass ich wieder reinkomme.
Mal gucken, ob es hier jetzt geht. Nee, es ruckelt auch noch. Fuck man, wie kann das
so kaputt sein? So ist es nicht gedacht. Eher gedacht, dass die uns hier abfarben können
von der Seite. Auch nice. Guck mal da. Hallo. Wo kommen sie hier? Massive Spray. Das ist
übrigens auch wahnsinnig gutes Design hier. Einfach mal offenes offenes Dünenfeld. Achtung
damit. Ist das die Shotgun Leute? Ist das die? Ist das die Shotgun? Die mich da gerade
gekillt hat? Ist das diese angebliche One Shot Shotgun? Nee, das nicht. OK. MonkaS. MonkaS.
Alter. By the way, warum ich nicht geaimt habe, ist folgendes. Ich dachte mir, es ist
besser in Bewegung zu bleiben, anstatt anstatt ins Iron-Sein hoch zu gehen. Aber gut, man
ist nachher immer schlauer. So einen Rats wäre mega poggers, falls wir einen kriegen,
ich glaube nicht. Die awnen die gerade. Guck mal hier. Ich glaube die bashen die gerade.
Na ja nice. Medic Oma. Nein, du musst mich ratzen. Mich. Nice. Nice. Guck mal, du schaffst
es überhaupt nicht zum M kommen, bis das gelegt ist. Es bringt nichts, da muss ich
gar nicht hin. Ich schaff es nicht bis dahin. Es ist sinnlos überhaupt dahin zu rennen.
Die Zeit des M-Coms genügt nicht, um einmal über die Map zu rennen. Depega Style oder?
Das ist das. Ist es das oder nicht? Das geht oder Panzer?
Pants Man fährt im Kreis da oben. Oh, der Pants Man. Oh, gerade noch weggekommen.
Okay, jetzt müsste ich halt wissen, wo die sind. Hier ist nichts mehr. Okay, wir sollten
mal zu B. Wir sollten mal zu B. Alles klar. Game. Sehr gut. Du bist in meiner Lobby.
Gegnerteam oder mein Team? Wir haben es. Nice. Es ist übrigens auch sehr irritierend, dass
die Gegner noch was sagen, wenn sie schon tot sind. Da denkst du immer, da ist noch
einer, da bist da gar keiner. Sehr, sehr, sehr viel undurchdachte Dinge. Vielleicht
können wir ihn rausschießen. Pass mal auf. Das ging am Anfang. Am Anfang ist der Crabbling
Hook quasi durch, durchgegangen. Zumindest sollten wir nicht im offenen laufen, solange
der Healy hier rumstellt. Oh, oh, der Pants Man. Nichts wie weg. Oh, get fucked up in
die Hose. Ich glaube, die sind, wir müssen mal so einen Tier Ranking von den Waffen machen.
Im Prinzip ist alles die Tier, bis auf ein paar die sind ganz gut. 74 ist ganz gut. 24
ist ganz gut. 9 30 ist ganz gut und die DMS ganz gut. Ansonsten kannst du den Rest eigentlich
mehr oder weniger vergessen. Wie sind die noch hier? Nee, das kriegen wir nicht. Keine
Chance. Ich habe dich schon zweimal gekillt. Ups. Machen wir es so, machen wir es so. Wenn
ich es noch, wenn ich es nicht schaffe, fünf Mal zu killen, dann kriege ich dein Prime-Sub.
Wobei, nee, nee, nee, das ist ja blödsinn. Das ist ja gar kein Anreiz. Das ist ja gar
kein Anreiz. Wenn du es fünf Mal schaffst, mich zu killen, dann kriege ich dein Prime-Sub,
weil so gewinne ich immer irgendwas. Das finde ich eigentlich einen sinnvolleren Ansatz als
umgedreht. So hat jeder was. Du hast den Win und ich habe den Prime-Sub. Oder umgedreht,
ich habe den Win, du kannst den Prime-Sub behalten. Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das sollten wir öfter so machen. Ey, by the way, auch noch was. Wer bei DICE diesen Granatwerfer
designt hat, der gehört gekickt. Das ist die most useless Waffe im gesamten Spiel. Oh,
guck mal, da wird geteabacked. So, jetzt wird es hier schwierig, wir müssen darüber. Wo
sind denn die M-Coms hier überhaupt? Hier ist das M-Com, okay. Oh, die sind schon am
Start. Hier ist keiner. Ich muss hier durch, der Heli basht mich sonst. Alter Webster,
heile dich doch. Hier geht es aber gerade rund drin. Ist Webster Premium? Guck mal,
das ist ein Up-T-Back, null. Webster ist Level 15, du musst das anloggen. Wie gesagt Max,
ich kann dich entweiten, wenn du am Start bist. Ist er aber nicht. Enemy Forces. Er spielt
sich wirklich wie 30 FPS, Leute. Das Memory Leak kickt gerade richtig rein. Man sieht es
witziger, weil es an den FPS nicht. Aber es ist so, ich merke es. Es rockelt und leckt
as fuck. Okay, nice. Von der Seite. Du hast mich geteabacked, das ist doch nice. Wer mag
es nicht, geteabacked zu werden. Hyper Gachi. Letzter Base. Leute, danach mache ich noch
ein, zwei Runden und dann muss ich mal sowas von trinken aufs Klo. Pe-Pu-Pu-Pu machen.
Alles klar, Game. Alles klar, alles klar. Gibt es eigentlich in Warzone aktuell auch
richtige OP-Waffen? Ist jemand da so im Warzone-Game, Warzone-Meta? Irgendwie drinne gerade. Nice,
diese Waffe ist auf Range top. Gibt es die nicht immer? Doch. Aber ich weiß nicht welche.
Welche ist dann gerade OP in Warzone? Ich habe nämlich tatsächlich mir überlegt, ob
ich nicht, wenn diese Pazifik-Karte rauskommt, ob ich mir nicht echt noch mal Warzone gebe,
weil Battlefield, ich spiele aktuell relativ viel Halo, was auch mega Bock macht, aber
Battlefield kattet es dieses Jahr halt einfach nicht so für mich. 187G. Ja, ich habe doch
jetzt eine extra SSD, da kann das drauf. Die drücken aber gut die Gegner. Die drücken
gut, Gatschi-Buzz. Auf geht's. Aber da gehe ich nicht runter. Okay, ich muss rüber. Wenn
ich nicht rüber gehe, das macht keiner. Game, Mann. F***, Alter. Guck mal, wie viele stehen.
Ne, keine Chance. Du, du, du. Du, du, du, du. Ich muss das Spiel neu starten, weil es leckt
wie Sau. Petel, du kannst ja, wobei, ne, wir gehen raus, wir suchen danach neu, vielleicht
können wir noch mal ein bisschen Attacker spielen. Ich habe jetzt genug Defended. Lull, das reicht.
Wir haben es eh verloren, ich starte mal schnell neu. So, play. Das hat wirklich so heftig
geleckt gerade. Siehst du das kritisch mit dem Colonel Treiber für Anti-Cheat? Tja,
schon lange, aber ich verstehe die Notwendigkeit. Also, das ist ja so easy Anti-Cheat und was
sonst nicht noch alles gibt. Ach, ich habe Display. Leute, habe ich die ganze Zeit schon
Display Capture. Der Stream muss doch geleckt haben wie Sau. Oder hat er nicht geleckt?
War gut. Hä? Dann verstehe ich es nicht. Aber das Lag in Game lag nicht da dran. Das
ist schon mal klar. Das liegt an diesem komischen Memory League in Battlefield. So, Social. Ach,
das ist das Game. Ja, es ist auch das Game. So, vielleicht sind wir jetzt noch mal Attacker.
Da habe ich jetzt Bock drauf, noch mal eine Runde Attacker. Noch zwei, drei Runden Attacker.
Das wäre noch mal Pock. Ja, bei mir laggt es auch. Es gibt zwei Sachen. Wenn das Spiel
zu viel CPU zieht. Mal gucken. Wenn wir nicht Attacker sind, suche ich neu. Dann laggt es
im Stream, weil das irgendwie mit OBS nicht hinterherkommt. Und wenn es für mich laggt,
ist es aber immer eine Game-Geschichte. Wenn es für euch laggt, ist es vielleicht auch
eine OBS-Geschichte. Aber höchstwahrscheinlich eine Game-Geschichte. Sind wir Attacker? Wir
sind, wir sind, wo sind wir denn? Defender? Nee, Leave Game. Exit. Dieser Fisch? Dankeschön
für den Sub. Bist du dieser Fisch von YouTube? Von vor ein paar Jahren? Oder bist du einfach
nur zufällig dieser Fisch? Bist du dieser Fisch, wo ich mit dem mal mit Kaboom mit zusammen
All You Can Eat stellst? Fressen war in Frankfurt. Genau der. Nice. Du bist eindeutig. Es gibt
so manche Sachen, die können nur die Leute. Alter, Game, come on. Es gibt so Sachen,
das wissen nur die Leute, die dabei waren. Der Goldcock, genau. Yep, Yep, Goldcock.
Ist auch so hängen geblieben. Jawoll, please Attacker, lasst mich noch 2, 3 Runden Attacker
spielen bis 22 Uhr. Attacker, Preyge, Leute, Preyge, Preyge, Preyge. Attacker. Preygege,
Prey, Prey, Prey, Prey, Preyge hat funktioniert, Leute. Es hat funktioniert. Preyget, Preyget.
Sag mal, fehlt, sag mal, fehlt dem Crapling Hook der Lauf, wenn der so rennt? Der fehlt,
guck mal, der fehlt, der fehlt der Lauf vorne, oder? Oder nicht? Oh man, Game, please nicht
drum baggen. Tango down, Tango, Tango, Tango, Tango, Tango down. Tango Sucker. Lul, wie
es erst nicht registrat hat. Oder habe ich nicht getroffen? Wahrscheinlich habe ich beides.
Es hat nicht registrat und ich habe nicht getroffen. Gehe ich mal von aus, war wahrscheinlich
beides fail. Ah, fuck. Der Frontgriff steht einfach nur vorne. Ja, das dachte ich auch
am Anfang, aber dann passt die Ansicht, wenn man die Waffe normal hält, nicht? Guck, guck,
der Frontgriff ist da unten, also der, oh Gott, jetzt ist ja gut, man. Dann würde es nicht
zusammenpassen. Oder, oder ich, oder meine Augen haben einfach nicht die richtige Perspektive.
Der Yolos, wir spielen gegen den Yolo Swagger. Ich glaube, wir können eigentlich gar nicht
gewinnen. Sag mal, da fuck. Wie soll man gegen den Yolo Swagger? Der Fisch Nummer drei hat
auch Subscribed. Danke, danke. Wie soll man gegen den Yolo Swagger dann auch gewinnen?
Das ist eigentlich impossible. Impossible. Yolo Swagger. Fuck man, in the ass, von unten,
ah, da kann man durchgucken. Das wusste ich nicht, dass man nur durchgucken kann. Das
war pepega dumm. Da machst du nichts, aber wenn wir Glück haben, können wir auf dem
Dach neu spawnen. Jawoll. Poggers Spawn, auf dem Dach. Okay, das wird so nichts. Vielleicht
sollte ich mal, vielleicht sollte ich mal ein paar Rauchgranaten mitnehmen. Ich habe das
Gefühl, Rauchgranaten könnten tatsächlich echt was bringen in dem Fall. Ja, unser Poggers
Spawn ist noch am Start. Was ist denn hier Rauch? Hey, fuck.
Ich warte jetzt, bis sie diffusen.
Shit. Ich meine, es war gut gedacht.
Es war gut gedacht, das müsst ihr zugeben.
Mann, game please. Was trifft mich hier eigentlich? Chat, was trifft mich? Was trifft mich?
Ich verstehe das Spiel nicht.
Die Löschanlage. Oh ja, das war wichtig einzubauen. Nichts in dem Spiel funktioniert, aber Hauptsache,
die Löschanlage klappt.
Das war enorm wichtig, das zu implementieren. Funktionierte Löschanlage. Pogger. Fuck,
Uni leer. Gerade mal andere Ansichten gegoogelt, alles okay. Okay. Nee, nee, ich meine das
natürlich ernst. Das ist schon wichtig. Ich meine, man weiß es ja in so Lagerhallen,
dass die Löschanlage funktioniert. Das ist eigentlich essentiell.
Ach, wir müssen B noch holen. Ich noob. Ich dachte, wir haben es schon. Das Spiel ist
so kaputt, guckt euch mal. Hallo. Funktioniert halt mal. Oh, von hinten, von hinten, von
hinten. We got fucked up in the ass over here. Ich hab den links gesehen, by the way.
Oh, hier ist ja gar nix. Hier ist ja gar nix. Wo müssen wir denn hin? Wo müssen wir denn
hin? Wo sind die obendrauf, oder? Die K30 sinkt richtig rein. Du hättest nicht gedacht,
dass ich noch existiere. Naja, so alt bin ich jetzt auch noch nicht. Ich bin zwar alt,
aber so alt auch noch nicht. Also ich bin noch nicht unter der Erde. Kettner stellt
ja 85 plus. 85 plus. Battlefield Opa FPS bei Wilhelm Kramer 2.0.
Kennt noch jemanden, Wilhelm Kramer LP? Das ist klar. Weiß gar nicht, ob es hier noch
gibt. Wo die Leute früher gesagt haben, das ist bestimmt Kollege. Ich dachte mir so immer
schon seit der Zeit total hängen geblieben, Leute. Warum sollte es Kollege sein? Der hat
besseres zu tun, als Wilhelm Kramer LP auf YouTube zu machen. Aber gut, die Leute auf
YouTube haben schon immer viel Stuss erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist. Also eine wirklich
gute Range Waffe ist das nicht. Halber Skandal, das kann echt der Opa war. Ja, die Leute
sind auch richtig hängen geblieben. Ich meine, das war klar, dass es weder Kollege ist, noch
dass es ein richtiger Opa ist. Also keine Ahnung. Es gibt schon nicht so high IQ Leute
auf YouTube. Was ist deine Meinung zu dem neuen Battlefield? Ich bin schwer enttäuscht.
Ernsthaft jetzt. No Copper. Ich kann es jetzt Video zu angucken. Ich bin wirklich schwer
enttäuscht von dem Game. Unfertig, undurchdacht. Bugs ohne Ende. Wobei die Bugs ganz ehrlich,
die Bugs sind nicht mal mein größtes Kritikpunkt. Mein größter Kritikpunkt, dass es einfach
kein richtiges Battlefield mehr ist und so undurchdacht ist an vielen Stellen. Kann
man da oben drauf Big Brain? Kranstells? Nee, hat nicht funktioniert. Wo ist der denn?
Ohne Granate. Bäm, Bäm, kaputt. Oh, das ist ganz schlecht für mich hier. Ganz schlecht
für mich. Okay. Pass auf, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo.
Okay, jetzt ein Motionball hin. Okay, hier kommt nix. Game, komm on, funktionier halt.
Game, funktionier please. Was, was, was ist mit dem Spiel los? So broken. Oh shit. Also
normalerweise sollte mich der Crabling hoch oben aufs Dach ziehen. Anstatt dreimal hintereinander
nicht zu funktionieren. Oh sorry, ich hab nicht gesehen, dass du mich retzen willst.
Released. Wie nennt man das eigentlich? Released ist noch so dark, MMO, Jargon. Wie nennt man
das eigentlich offiziell? Wenn man, also Chet, wie nennt man das, wenn jemand dich retzen
will, aber du respawnst schon so schnell, bevor er dich retzen kann. Gibt's da irgendwie
ein tolles, tolles englisches Anglizismus Wort für? In dark hat man dazu gesagt released.
Oh, I got shot in the ass over here. Dafür gibt's den Wort, nee, nee, respawn ist ja
das eigentliche, wie die erscheinen auf der Map. So dieses, oh, dieses zu früh, zu früh
rausgehen. Da muss es, da muss es ein richtig krasses Anglizismus Wort für geben und das
will ich benutzen. Early, ähm, da brauchen wir irgendwas für, Leute. Da brauchen wir
irgendwas für. Irgendwas. Okay, das war zu mutig. Gibt's Leute, die Hexazone spielen?
Nö. Ich glaube Hexazone spielt keiner. Ich hab zwei, drei Runden gespielt für diese
Dice Promotion bei mir auf dem Channel. Ansonsten ist es glaube ich dead. Und wenn es nicht
free to play wird und auch sehr, sehr, sehr viel Liebe bekommt, wird's auch dead bleiben.
Deadge. Oh, einer, der sich nie aus der Hüftehals sprechen lassen. Sunnybaited, das finde
ich gut. Early Sunnybait. ESB, Early Sunnybait, das finde ich gut. Wir brauchen mehr Anglizismen.
Ich benutze schon, ich benutze schon viel zu wenig englische Wörter. Sagen die Leute
ja auch auf YouTube immer unter den Videos. Die sagen, Junge, was laberst du? Sind aber
einfach nur zu noob, high IQ speak zu verstehen. Äh. Ich habe jetzt keine Ahnung, wo hier
was ist. Ich weiß nur, dass ich einen Motion Sensor brauche. Alter, guckste dir an. Die
Typen mit ihren Panzerplates. Guck mal hier, die halten gut. Die, die, die halten voll
dagegen. 33 Tickets nur noch. MonkaS, wir verlieren die Runde ja vielleicht. Was ist
denn hier los? So geht es aber nicht. Wir können, wir können nicht einfach losen. Guck mal,
guck mal, der LLV, der LLV ist so schlecht, man. Habt ihr gesehen, der LLV, der ist so
richtig, also so schlecht kannst du gar nicht sein, wie der LLV ist. Ich möchte jetzt ungern
da als erstes vorstellen. Achtung, bunnyhop, volle Pulle, bunnyhop, jawoll, excellent, excellent
und jetzt hoch, jetzt hoch. BigBrain stellt's, auf geht's. Da oben erwartet mich jetzt,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Okay, verstecken
und einen heiligen Corona Booster reindrücken. Oh, da kommt, oh fuck, in the ass geshootet.
Sag mal Max, werden heutzutage noch in der Zukunft Linux Adminen? Ja, klar. Ich hab erst,
ich hab erst mit einem Kollege telefoniert am letzten Arbeitstag, der irgendwelche Storage
Geschichten bei uns gemacht hat, der geht jetzt zu einer anderen Firma, lustigerweise
auch zu einer anderen Bank und macht dort Linux, weil die interne Linux Leute gesucht
haben, was ich richtig cool finde, dass es das noch gibt. Alter, der hat ja mich ernsthaft
gerade noobtubt, hat er mich noobtubt? Oh, oh, massive res. Foff hochstellen, nee, ich
komm mit hohem Foff, lustigerweise, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich komm mit hohem Foff in diesem
Battlefield 3 nicht klar. Ich glaube, ich hab, was hab ich, 90er oder 80er Foff? Ich
glaub 90er, ich komm mit, ich komm mit mehr Foff nicht klar. Sehr merkwürdig, ich weiß
nicht, woran das liegt. Vielleicht, vielleicht Performancegründe oder so. Ich fände es
nice, wenn mein Craplinghook ready kommt, dass ich da hoch kann. Nee, das hat jetzt
aber, das war schwere Geburt, schwere Geburt. Alter, da ist ne Muni-Kiste, da muss ich hin.
Ich brauche Muni. All dies unten. Geht es noch jemand so, dass ihr gar nicht, dass man
gar nicht richtig erkennt auf der Map, ob es ne Muni-Kiste ist oder ob es ne Medic-Kiste
ist? Was ist das hier vor mir, Chat? Ist das ne Medic-Kiste oder ist das ne Muni-Kiste?
Ich erkenne es irgendwie nicht richtig auf der Map. Massive-Range-Waffe. Muni? Medic,
was denn jetzt, Chat? Ich sehe es, ihr seid euch auch nicht einig. Ich bräuchte mal, bräuchte
mal ein bisschen Munition. Ich bräuchte noch mehr Munition. Ist der hier oben drauf?
Er muss da. Oh, oh. Bam! Voll in die Fresse. Sollte ich eigentlich ein bisschen Ammo droppen?
Ich mag das Movement mit Webster wirklich. Es kann nicht alles doof in dem Game. Aber
der Rest ist halt so. P-P-P-P-Pega. Pega. Oh, ich hab immer keine Motion-Sensors, ich
hab Smoke immer noch. Passt mal auf, geht das? Ich hab gedacht, man kann sich da vielleicht
dran schießen. Geht doch! Geht doch, manchmal geht das. Das war wahrscheinlich einfach zu
weit weg. Oh Gott, P-P-Pega. Zwei Leute, die nicht aimen können unter sich.
Das war ja richtig hängen geblieben, Alter. Zu geil eben. Aber wir haben's, wir haben's,
wir haben's. Richtig P-P-Pega aimt alle beide und sich dann gemessert gegenseitig.
Okay, ich darf nicht wieder. Oh, oh. Ach, da kommt noch ne Base. Ist das die längste
Rush-Map? Kann das sein? Oh nee, das sind immer vier, ne? Bin verwirrt. Da oben ist
er noch. Ich hoffe, der Pantsman sieht mich nicht. Der müsste hier oben, wir sind überhaupt
nicht clear, was der Ansager wieder für'n Shit erzählt. Wir sind definitiv not not clear.
So, wir nebeln den Dude jetzt einfach mal ein. Pass mal auf, big brain play. Wir nebeln den
jetzt ein und jetzt sieht uns natürlich keiner. Und stellts ihn hier hoch, so muss das sein.
So magisch das. Way too smart. Way too smart. Wie das? Work smart, not hard. Ach, da geht's
noch höher. Oh, nicer, nicer. Klitschspot. Passt mal auf, wir boosten uns da jetzt hoch.
Komm her. Big brain mode activated, Leute. Und jetzt noch eins weiter, noch eins weiter.
Ja. Oh man, das gibt's net. Was macht der Dude? Was macht der da? Warum ist der da?
Was macht der denn hier? Keine Sau sollte hier oben sein. Streamsniper, Leute, Streamsniper,
wer ist es von euch? Wer ist es von euch? Jetzt zu. Warum sollte der Typ sonst hier oben
sein? BP gar elmt, richtig krass.
Nee, nee, nee, noch mal, noch mal geht hier, geht hier nix.
Einen haben wir da. Alle weg. Au, war auf mich zu schneiden. Oh fuck, in dem Moment, wo ich
runtergehe, kommen die hoch. Dumm. Die Musik ist richtig paper please, ja. Dustin, danke
für den Sub. Wir sollten es schaffen, denke ich. Wir brauchen nur noch A. Oh, da waren
ganz schön viele. Wenn man jetzt Trick 17 stellt. Get rekt. Tyrannosaurus rekt.
So macht man das, Leute, so macht man das. Fatal, ich hole dich. Nein, Fatal, ich hole
dich nicht. Ich kämpfe jetzt hier, weil wenn das kaputt geht, Hände hoch, Wochenende, jawohl,
Bam. Wochenende, Schwachsinn. Dummes Gelaber, aber easy win easy win. Anstrengend. Too easy.
Wisst ihr, diese Cringe Sprüche, die hätten richtig, also es gibt zwei Varianten, entweder
die hätten halt so realistisches Battlefield Zeug machen müssen, so irgendwie so Military
Talk, wisst ihr, das hätte funktioniert, oder die hätten so richtig in die Elite Ecke
gehen müssen. Der Typ hätte einfach sagen müssen easy as fuck oder irgendwie sowas
am Ende. Eats AF oder irgendwie sowas. Das wäre schon so übertrieben gewesen, dass es
die Leute gefeiert hätten. Aber so dieses nix halbes und nix ganzes Cringe Sprüche
sind halt Cringe. Also genau, der hätte entweder easy as fuck sagen müssen und einen Backflip
machen, so richtig voll übertrieben. So Bad Company 2 Style nur noch heftiger. Oder sie
hätten halt irgendwelches Military Speak machen müssen. Jens Kappa ist bei uns. Na,
da kann ja eigentlich nix, Jens Kappa ist raus. Da kann eigentlich gar nix mehr schief gehen,
aber so. So, wo geht man rein? Auto? Ach, man muss Sponsor nur für das Auto, ok. Volle
Pulle B, Volle Pulle B. Gib ihm. Es ist auch Cringe, dass wir schon legen können, bevor
die Defender richtig da. Wow. Oder kommt einer von der Seite, der killt mich gleich. Pack,
das war mir zu viel. Oder das Gelaber ganz einfach weglassen. Das wäre auch eine Möglichkeit
gewesen, das Gelaber einfach wegzulassen, ja. Und das komplette Auto wegzulassen. Denn,
genialer Spawn. Denn das Gelaber braucht, wenn man ehrlich ist, kein Mensch. Oh fuck, dachte
mir, es wird noch was. Warum spawne ich Dreck unter mir? Ok, das sind mal Gegner, die Widerstand
leisten, wie es aussieht. Zumindest etwas. Oh shit, jetzt bin ich down. Fuck. Oder auch
nicht. Fuck. Warum ist die nicht umgekippt? Der Pressart. Der Pressart hat mich geschreckt.
Das wäre noch viel schöner, wenn hier unten auch ein bisschen was abgehen würde. Sehr
gut durchdacht, wieder Dice. Ey, what the hell. Funktioniert ja richtig gut. Ok, das sind
definitiv mal Gegner, die Gegenwehr leisten. Da müssen wir was machen. Am besten direkt
mit dem LLV drüber fahren. Wobei der LLV macht ja keinen Damage an Infanterie, habe
ich ja vergessen. Massive, nicer Spawn. Irgendwo ist doch hier nur einer. Wo sind sie denn?
Oh, da oben. Oh, Alter, jetzt haben sie aber von allen Seiten Attacks dort.
Spielst du auf hohen oder niedrigen Grafikeinstellungen? Ich spiele auf den niedrigsten Grafikeinstellungen,
die es gibt. Und warum ich jetzt sogar noch ein bisschen mehr FPS habe liegt daran, weil
es 16 vs. 16 Rush ist und 16 vs. 16 ein bisschen mehr FPS hat als... Warum man sich gedacht
hat, das ist eine gute Idee, dass die in unseren Spawn schießen können und wir in ihren Spawn
nach der nächsten Base. I don't know. Horge. Horge erst. Ich will da nicht als erster rein,
ehrlich gesagt. O-oh. O-oh. Beringer. Fuck. Please sterben.
Alter, die sind ja überall. Seht ihr mal, wie schlecht der LRV ist? Habt ihr das gesehen?
Progress, Progress. Fuck. Die sind auf Zack, die Gegner. Das merkst du sofort, wenn du
auf Zack kommst. Dann ist das halbes ESL-Match. Direkt auf Zack. Vielleicht kann ich da Spawn
sollen? Sollte man nicht hier eigentlich drin Spawn können? Okay, jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Wenn der Angriff nicht klappt, haben wir gelitten und ich glaube nicht, dass der klappt.
Wir sind auf Zylinder-Driving. Orgas. Exquisite-Driving. Nicht am fucking Felsen hängen bleiben,
aber das ist die Runde. Richtig hart geschwitzt ist die Runde. Es ist aber auch nicht richtig
balanced. Mal rasiert man, mal wird man rasiert. So ist es halt, Leute. Und ich sage euch,
so muss es sein. So muss es sein. Diese ganze Skill-Base-Matchmaking-Scheiß. Ich habe kein
Problem, wenn ich manchmal auf den Zack kriege. Aber so dieses permanente 50-50-Zack-Teil einfach.
Moment. Chat, was geht ab? Hallo. Jetzt, da ich endlich mal den Stream erwische, wenn
es nicht gerade zu Ende geht. Ja, Pech manchmal. Wie ist die Performance vom Battle? Schlecht.
Immer noch schlecht. Immer noch schlecht. Die wird nicht besser sein. Muss die ja keine
Hoffnung machen. Wisst ihr was auch witzig ist, dass die in ihren ganzen Patch-Geschichten,
oh, Hauer Class, come on. Dass sie in ihren ganzen Patch-Geschichten nichts zu Performance-Improvements
wirklich sagen. Warum man sich beim Liegen im Aim nicht bewegen kann, weil das die Noobs
überfordert. Du kannst doch nicht die Noobs überfordern. Die müssen sich Skins kaufen.
Das geht aber nicht. Stell dir mal vor, die müssen eine Taste zum Hinlegen drücken und
können noch während dem Liegen links und rechts robben. Nee, das geht nicht. Das geht
nur wirklich nicht. Das kannst du nicht machen. Das kannst du nicht bringen 2021. Legacy Feature,
das geht nicht. Ja, so sieht es aus. Legacy Feature. Dieses Bunnyhop, das finde ich tatsächlich
ganz witzig. Jetzt geht es Omikron am Start. Alter, Monarch S. Ich habe die Gegner gesehen.
Ich hoffe, die nehmen mich nicht.
Ich höre die ja diffusen. F***, das ist zu viel. Alter, ich bin gerade voll am sterben.
Alter, ich bin voll am abkratzen. Mit wieviel DPI? 800. Ja ja, Omikron, jetzt vorbei. Gibt
es das eigentlich in Hessen schon? Hat Hessen schon den ersten Fall? Hoffe ja nicht. Objective
Alpha. Jetzt pass auf, richtig krasse Stells Action. Riechtiger, richtiger Five-Hand-Stell.
Wir stellen uns von der Seite rein. Hallo, Digger Sack. Ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich dachte,
Big Brain Play, dabei haben die mich outplayed. Fluffykick sagt, er findet die Maps so hässlich.
Ja, da bist du nicht der einzige. Ich finde die Map nicht nur hässlich, ich finde die
Map auch schlecht zu spielen. Das ist ja die fatalste Kombination. Schlecht zu spielen
und sieht kacke aus. Alles dead? Alles dead? Und Scheiben. Lohnt sich das Game nach? Nein,
das ist glaube ich die häufigst schnellste Frage, nicht nur des Tages, sondern der ganzen
Battlefield Streams. Nein, das Game lohnt sich vor den Patches nicht, das Game lohnt
sich auch nach den Patches nicht. Und ich gehe mal davon aus, das Game wird sich eine
sehr sehr lange Zeit nicht lohnen, wenn überhaupt, jemals. Ich sage es euch, wie es ist. Ich
habe kein Interesse dran, irgendwie hier was zu sellen, was nicht... Wozu auch? Kriege
ich immer Geld für. Wenn mir DICE irgendwie 2000€ Monatsgehalt als Battlefield Anpreiser
bezahlen würde, ja gut, dann erzähle ich alles mögliche. Aber was willst du machen?
Aber ansonsten, sage ich was Sache ist. Ist Rush jetzt für kurze Zeit Standard? Das weiß
ich nicht so genau. Es ist eine dieser angebließenen Playlists, was im Prinzip heißt, es könnte
jederzeit rausfliegen, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es dazu ein Statement gibt. Sollten
die Rush rausschmeißen, das ist das dümmste, was sie machen könnten, weil Rush ist das
einzige, was sich in diesem Spiel halbwegs spielenswert ist. Jaja, jaja. Achtung, wir
machen jetzt Schildstells. Schildstells. Hätte ja funktionieren können. Location Revealed,
oh nein. Meine Location ist Revealed. Da machst du nichts, da muss ich jetzt eigentlich gleich
raus. Da bin ich gleich heim. Übrigens auch so ein Ding, in alten Battlefields bist du
in der gleichen Pose gespawnt, wie der Typ, bei dem du gespawnt bist, wisst ihr was ich
meine? Alles klar. Hier nicht. Oh, Pogas Ratz, Pogas Ratz. Nein, nicht Pogas Ratz. Pogas
Ratz, noch mal ein. Zwei Stück gehen da nicht. Oh, nice, nice, nice. Ein Spawn Beacon. Jawoll.
Beacon. Alter, wie soll man denn hier durch, wie genau hat man sich das bei DICE vorgestellt,
an dieser Stelle? Was ist da jetzt so, was ist der, was ist the way? Was ist der Plan?
Ich war hinter der Säule. Es gibt kein TDM in All Out Warfare. Nein, All Out Warfare
TDM finde ich ist echt eine gute Idee. Die müssten die Maps glaube ich trotzdem ein
Ticken kleiner machen. Ihr habt eine Panzer hier, ich sehe nicht, irgendwo hier stellst
herum da. Ja, wunderbar. Ich spreide jetzt einfach nur wild rein. Sieht doch schon mal
viel besser aus. Das sieht doch schon mal viel besser aus jetzt. Alter, kannst du dich
mal heilen? Pippo Fett, Webster. Was? What the fuck? Hit Detection please, come on. Warum
war die nicht tot? Es ist einfach wieder die Hälfte durchgeflogen. Anders kann ich mir
das nicht erklären. Ich habe jetzt so viele gekillt. Da muss doch jetzt mal irgendwie,
da muss doch jetzt was gehen hier. Bam, bam, bam, auf geht's. Durch hier, durch, next,
fuck. Ist ja sehr nett. Oh ja, tolle Idee. Da ist ein Auto. Ich fahre keinen Panzer,
was sag ich? Rein da. Rum, rum, rum. Monkastier. Monkastier. Vielleicht haben wir Glück. Paar
Leute sind da, wir gehen eher dahin. Wir gehen eher dahin würde ich sagen. Weil da haben
wir noch paar Monkastiers am Start. Okay, kann ich mitleben. Geht ja nicht. Du wartest
mich am M-Kombi da. Nice, nice, das ist ein guter Plan. Ich würde auch nicht einfach
so rein sporen und 3 Stunden rennen. Warum auch? Nice, die lege Henne ist on air. Was
macht der hier? Was ist er hier am Doen? Aus dem Fatal Fast zu Killen. Dich Killen. Stream
Schneiber. Ich muss, geht nicht anders. Alles immer Stream Schneiber. Oh, die diffusen,
ich habe nix gesehen. Dumme Kacke, wenn es nicht richtig funzt, was es eigentlich funzen
sollte. Aber dadurch, dass ich jetzt eingesmoked habe, habe ich glaube ich, haben wir ganz
gute Chancen vor zu pushen. Ja, guck mal hier. Da ist er schon. Ne, der ist da dauernd. Oh,
ich kriege den Rats. Der Rats, da ist er. Oh, ich habe keine Muni mehr. Oh, nice, nice.
Alter, oh. Monka, da geht es aber gerade mal richtig, richtig zu sagen. Nein, nein, nein,
nicht diffusen, Alter, nicht diffusen. Macht den Fatal, lebt der noch? Ne, ne, ich glaube
so bewegt man sich in dem Spiel nicht, wenn man noch lebt. Nein, nein, nein, da geht
einer ran. No. Bam. Die hat die Reetaste nicht gefunden. Für so Leute, wie die Sundance
eben, ist das gemacht, damit, dass man sich nicht hinlegen kann und gleichermaßen sich
bewegen. Weil ihr habt es gesehen, die hat es nicht geschafft, an das M-Com ranzugehen
und E zu drücken. Und wenn man es nicht schafft, an ein M-Com ranzugehen und E zu drücken,
kann man noch nicht erwarten, dass man sich hinlegen kann und dabei moveen. Nein, schlechte
Idee. Gute Idee. Alter, man bleibt doch mal stehen. Okay. Sehr gut. Monka, stehe. Leute,
weg, während ich hier liege. Das muss jetzt einfach mal an der Stelle sein. Bis ich respawned
bin. Sonst lag das Game. Muss es leider umschalten. Lass mich reinspawnen, please. Reinspawn,
reinspawn, reinspawn, reinspawn, reinspawn, reinspawn, reinspawn. Da ist was. Da war was.
Tollisch. Ui. Blup. Warum haben eigentlich in diesem Battlefield alle einen D-Feeder
bei? Ist das irgendwie...nice Logik? Egal, das Spiel hat keine Logik. Warum frage ich
an Logik? Lul. Logik overrated, jebaited, outdated. Äh. Hallo? Der hat einfach nicht
geschossen. Aber das ist schon das Dritte, was manchmal Aussetzer hat. Springen geht
manchmal gar nicht, Nahkampfen geht manchmal...Nahkampfen, Alter. Melee geht manchmal gar nicht und manchmal
geht anscheinend schießen auch nicht. Wo kämen wir auch hin, wenn in dem Shooter schießen
funktionieren würde. Das wäre ja komplett...Also wer kann...Also nee, das kann man ja nicht
erwarten. Das kann man ja beim besten Bild nicht erwarten. Das ist das Shooten einfach
über mir. Über uns sind die. Endgame, Alter. Up we go! Up we go!
Yolo Swagger. Der Yolo Swagger ist da. Endlich. Der Yolo Swagger. Der Yolo Swagger, da war er.
Nee, da war er nicht. Achtung, Flank Action. Der Yolo Swagger. Also Leute, ich muss sagen,
ich bin mit meiner Performance mittlerweile in Multiplayer-Spielen als 37-jähriger Boomer
eigentlich ganz zufrieden. Das war jetzt dumm, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir andere 37-Jährige
angucke, wie die Spiele spielen online, dann ist das durchaus in Ordnung. Nice Rats. Gut,
ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, die ältesten CS-Spieler sind nicht so viel jünger als
ich. Auch wenn die nicht mal so in ihrer Prime sind. Wie alt ist Guardian jetzt? Oder Test
oder so? Die sind doch auch schon irgendwie 34 oder sowas. Wer weiß, dass die jemand wie
alt sind. Richtig nice ist PP-GM. Oh, da schießt was auf mich. Guck mal hier, da kommt was
rüber und will mich shooten. Da kommt noch was. Monka Shoot. Alter, oh nee, ich hab nichts
mehr. Ich nebel mich jetzt einfach ein und warte hier. Alter, ich hör hier 50 Gegner
um mich drum herum und du weißt in diesem Battlefield nie, ob sie nah oder entfernt
sind. Monka S. Wir machen das Trick 17, guckt euch das mal an. Oh nee, hat nicht funktioniert.
Hat nicht gefunzt. Moni, Moni, Moni, gib mir Moni. Watch my back. Ok, pass auf, pass
auf, big brain move. Massive big brain move. Jawoll, jawoll, schießt mir nicht in Bobbes,
nicht in der Ice shooten. Sehr gut. Oh, in der Ask shootet. 37 ist das, 29. Ist so. Ich
sag euch Leute, die jetzt, also in meinem Alter und noch älter, die werden auch bis 70 plus
spielen und noch ganz ok sein können, wenn sie da in die nötige Zeit in den Game reinstecken.
Ich mein, ich merk das schon, dass ich jetzt nicht mehr so mega schnell in den Game rein
kommen wie früher vielleicht. Nein, die haben Disabled. Die Noobs. Hast du nicht mehr so
viel Zeit in den Westin? Naja, es hat schon seinen Grund, dass die ganzen, dass die ganzen
Competitive Pros alle irgendwie 16, 16 bis 25 sind oder so. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz
sicher, wo die Gegner sind. Ah fuck, ich hab ja noch, nein, ich brauch meine Motion Balls.
Shit, ich brauch die Motion Balls, sonst seh ich ja gar nichts. Nope, wir kriegen kein
Rest, passt nicht. Haben wir eigentlich schon ein M-Com geplantet hier? Banana Planter 27,
das wollte ich jetzt machen hier. Gib ihm, gib ihm. Oh man, ich spawn hier ernsthaft
mitten auf dem Feld, Alter. Keine, not, not Pog. Ich weiß, was hier, what? Not, not Pog.
Ich wollte runterlegen, da unten ist das M-Com vollkommen frei. Das ist doch unterirdisch,
das ist das M-Com. Not Pog, wo ist der Panz, der Panzman überhaupt, dass der mich da gehitted
hat? Genau, hier runter müssen wir. So, einmal Balls, einmal Balls. Und jetzt Legehennen
machen, Leute. Ach nee, haben wir das schon? Ich bin verwirrt. Zack. Ach, wir haben nur
noch das oben. Lull. Ja Mensch, sagt mir das doch mal einer. Boomer hier, das ist nicht
so schnell. Aber wir können jetzt da oben drauf. Okay, das ist definitiv not, not range weapon.
Fuck, jetzt sind sie oben. Da machst du nichts. Aber wir hätten im gleichen Moment, wo ich
da hinten Action mache in der Backline, hätten wir rüberpushen müssen. Aber wir haben einen
schönen Motion Sensor drin, das heißt, man sieht alles. Rätsel wird mich hier oben natürlich
keiner, das ist klar, wie auch. Nice, wir sind fast dran, Leute, wir sind fast dran.
Jetzt nicht sinnlos sterben, wir haben immer viele. Wir haben nur noch sechs Tickets. Nice,
wir sind fast dran. Oh, shit, shit, shit. Fuck, ich wusste, dass der von hinten kommt. Nein,
nein, nein. Aber der ist dead, der ist dead, da geht jetzt gleich noch einer ran. Ich habe
reloaded, ich hätte Pistole switchen müssen. Perfekt. Nein, das macht nichts, die kommen
nicht mehr ran, die kommen nicht mehr ran. Die kommen nicht mehr ran. Nein, nein, nein,
nein, da liegt einer und diffused. No. Not like this. Danach hätten wir gewonnen. Senden
soll die Klappe. Maria auch die Klappe halten. Webster auch die Klappe halten. Das war knapp,
das war richtig klaus, die Runde. Hipfire Kills, der mag das Game mag Hipfire Kills,
wie es aussieht. Fast Match of the Day. Jedes Match ist anscheinend noch dem Game Fast Match
of the Day. Was ist das XP Boost so zum Release oder was? Also ich denke, eine Runde kann
die noch spielen. Ich merke schon, dass man hier nicht mehr richtig mitmacht. Was? Ich
frage mich echt, warum die XP? Ja, weil es XP Farm Server gab, aber der Witz ist halt.
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Portal Trailer erinnern? Das erste, was ich gesagt habe,
ist, was machen die, dass es keine Booster Server gibt und BÄM, es gibt Booster Server.
Das hätte ja niemand, für mich auch die letzte Runde, hätte niemand ahnen können. Man könnte
das Ganze übrigens fixen. Also wenn die Bot Booster Server haben in Portal, dann einfach
abschalten, ist es gegen echte Spieler einfach, solange es die default Settings sind, was
Hells und sowas angeht, erlauben. Warum nicht? Ich meine, scheiß drauf. Warum nicht? Dann
sind die Leute Level 300, wem die juckts. Jetzt nochmal World War 3. Ich habe es versucht
zu deinstallieren, habe keinen Deinstaller gefunden und musste meinen Rechner von russischem
Anti-Cheat Deepnoten, das ich wegbekommen habe, Windows Service löschen und sonstige
Sachen klären, ich werde das nie wieder installieren. Zu viel russische K-K-K-K-Kommandat
Spyware drauf. Naja, nicht wirklich Spyware, kann man nicht sagen. Es ist halt legit Anti-Cheat,
aber keine, die ich haben will. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die sind. Es geschult. Ihr wollt
auch nicht flanken oder? Wollt ihr flanken? Wieder schön um die Ecke. LMG legit. Die kriegen
das glaub ich noch, die kriegen das noch diffused oder? Nein, nein, gut, gut, gut. Angel, retz
mich Angel. Angelo, gib mir. Voll in Ass, in Ass geballert. Wow. Macht's mit Rush wieder
richtig bock? Nein, es macht mit Rush erträglich. Rush macht das Spiel erträglich. Oben ist
doch einer. Nice, nice, der Viertel macht das. Nice, nice, nice. Gut, gleich das Loch getroffen
hier. Nach die Base. Vielleicht haben wir Glück. Nein. Das ist ein Sentry Gun da oben. Ich
geh da mal rein. Ich seh da zwar nix, aber wenn ich was sehen würde. Alter, ich kann
meine Waffe nicht wechseln. Ich kann nicht switchen. Meine Güte ey. Alter, ich kann
nicht anvisieren. Meine Iron Sides gehen nicht. Es ist broken. Es ist broken. Meine Iron Sides,
na jetzt geht's wieder. Meine Güte, Alter. Ein Shooter in dem Shooten nicht funktioniert.
Sehr gut gemacht da ist. Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog. Poggers. Ein, ein nicest, nicest
Game. Oh, aber den haben wir noch schön geklatscht. Shooten ist ja auch eine Legacy Mechanik, genau
wie Scoreboard. Richtig. Alles, alles Legacy. Alles was nicht funktioniert ist Legacy Feature,
das brauchen wir nicht. Es ist ja auch, sag mal so, reliable Waffen und Hit Detection in
dem Online-FPS. Also, wer kommt auf so eine Idee, dass man das bräuchte? Das ist ja komplett
overrated, outdated, outdated. Oh, nee. Panikhoppen hat man nicht von uns. Über Ranges? Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Der hat's auch nicht gecheckt, oder? The Nightbot ist schlau.
Rush mit 128 Spielern, das werde ich nicht spielen. Die können noch 24 Spieler erhöhen
und die Maps vielleicht ein bisschen besser ausnutzen. Aber ansonsten? Ich persönlich
finde ja eigentlich 16 versus 16 am besten. Auf Range ist die halt wirklich nicht so der
Bringer. Okay, jetzt rennen sie rüber, jetzt gehen wir hier hin. Sag mal, okay, ich hab
nicht jeden Schuss getroffen, ja? Okay. Aber. So mies war das jetzt auch nicht. Sag mal,
what the fuck? Kann ich den mal umkippen? Oder ist mein Boomer hier einfach zu lang gespielt?
Ich hätte nix mehr. Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein. Liegt es in dem Fall nicht mal am Game.
Metro, ja, aber Metro bitte nicht mit 128. Okay, da rechne ich da. Fuck! Ich dachte,
da rechne ich damit, dass ich direkt reiße. Oh, hier liegen sie. Das ganze, das ganze
Kaligua-Squad. Massive Spawn-Punkte, die sind so richtig pock, die Spawn-Punkte. In
the ass shooted. Jetzt liege ich hoffentlich, nein, ich liege in der Mauer. Webster, du
dicker Sack, leg dich nicht in die Mauer. Wenn ich in der Mauer bin, kann ich gerest
werden. Oh, kann auch so nicht gerest werden. Okay. Kein Q-Squad, nö, keiner da sonst.
Ich glaube, das wird nix. Leute, das wird nix. Wir haben nur noch 18 Tickets. Es wäre
übrigens sinnvoller, die Tickets ein bisschen hochzumachen. Die Katze möchte bei mir ins
Zimmer. Alter, Chico. Jetzt ist Chico drinnen. Reingestürmt. Richtig reingestellst ist
es. Oh, wir müssen hier lang. Leute, ich habe das Headset nicht richtig auf, ich weiß.
So, jetzt habe ich es richtig auf. Oh, jetzt die Legehennen machen. Legehennen. Legehennen.
Legehennen und abcampen. Legehennen und abcampen. Ich hoffe, es kommt keiner von der Seite. Boah.
Nein. Sie diffusen. Sie diffusen. Rip. Diffuse Champ. Diffuse Champ. Oh, was machen wir denn
hier? Was machen wir denn hier? Ganz, ganz dumme Idee, Max. Keine Chance. Chico, was
ist denn? Was ist los, Chico? Welche Maps würdest du noch wünschen? Terran Highway fände ich
geil. Das ist übelste Underrated-Map. Und natürlich sind das die Klassiker von Metro
bis Grand Bazaar, meinetwegen können die auch locker rein machen. Die können einfach
alle. Die sollen einfach alle Rush-Maps, Side-Bad-Copy, die eins reinschmeißen, 16 vs. 16. Easy.
Die sollen einfach die Spawns da lassen, wo sie sind und die M-Comp-Platzierungen da
lassen, wo sie sind. Fertig. Die müssen eigentlich gar nichts machen und schon wäre das viel
besser. Okay, Leute. Wenn die Katze schon am Start ist und rumnervt, das heißt schon
spät. Schon spät. Und schon spät bedeutet, ich gehe jetzt gleich pennen. Mal gucken,
ob ich den hosten kann. Nope, keiner da. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid. Wenn ihr
noch einen Prime-Sub übrig habt, würde ich mich freuen. Ansonsten könnt ihr euch auch
mal auf YouTube und auf Twitter vorbeigucken. Und morgen früh, 9.30 Uhr, so in dem Dreh,
wieder auf Wachstream. Wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut. See you.